हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबसे पहले हमेशा की तरह
आज भी मुझे बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है
क्या सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
ओके वेरी गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग
एनोनिमस ओके तो थैंक यू
तो जैसा कि लास्ट क्लास में
बहुत अच्छी क्लास चल रही थी हमारी और
सडनली पावर सप्लाई कट ऑफ हो गई मेरी साइड
से और मेरा इंटरनेट बंद हो गया था तो ना
तो आपको बताने का मौका मिला और मुझे किसी
और नंबर से या और किसी YouTube के पर
ज्वाइन करके मुझे क्या करना पड़ा आपको
मैसेज करना पड़ा और या मुझे क्या करना
पड़ा आपको tlegram ग्रुप के अंदर आपको
बताना पड़ा कि प्लीज समबडी बता दीजिए कि
मेरे साइड से इशू क्रिएट हो गया। तो उसके
लिए आई एम रियली रियली सॉरी बिकॉज़ मेरा भी
काफी अच्छा फ्लो था और मैं काफी अच्छे से
चीजें सिखा रहा था। उस दिन आप लोग भी काफी
ज्यादा प्रेजेंट थे और आप लोगों का
इंटरेस्ट भी आपको काफी इंटरेस्टिंग लग रहा
था। तो उस इंटरेस्ट को कंटिन्यू बरकरार
रखते हुए आज भी हम क्या करेंगे? क्लास को
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। वहीं से जहां पर हमने
प्रीवियस क्लास को छोड़ा था। क्योंकि हमने
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सिनेरियो के साथ स्टार्ट
किया था और काफी प्रोफेशनल स्टेप पर थे।
तो आई होप सबको मजा आया होगा सब लोगों को
इंटरेस्टिंग लगा होगा कि
कि हम बिल्कुल प्रोफेशनल तरीके से काम कर
रहे थे। तो डोंट वरी हम अपना
प्रोफेशनलिज्म हमेशा मेंटेन करेंगे और
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। तो सबसे पहले मैं आप
लोगों को एक चीज बता देता हूं कि जो नए
स्टूडेंट हैं जिसने अभी नई क्लासेस ज्वाइन
करना स्टार्ट किया है डीएचई के लिए तो
हमने क्या किया है कि आप लोगों के लिए कि
आपके जो डाउट्स हैं आपके डाउट्स कैसे लेने
हैं जैसे कि आप लोग यहां पर कमेंट्स में
डाउट नहीं देते लेकिन आप हो सकता है कि
कॉमन डाउट शेयर करना चाहते हो या फिर आपको
नोट्स चाहिए तो या आपको और कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
अनाउंसमेंट चाहिए जहां पर मैं क्या चाहता
हूं कि जहां
आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी के जितने भी स्टूडेंट
हो एक साथ इकट्ठे हो जाओ ताकि आप लोग क्या
कर सको आपस में भी मतलब आपस में तो नहीं
लेकिन आप अपने ऐसे डाउट शेयर कर सको हो
सकता है कि सेम डाउट आप लोगों के किसी और
दोस्त का आपके कलीग का आपके फ्रेंड का हो
जिससे क्या होगा कि एक साथ सबका डाउट
क्लियर हो जाएगा तो इसके लिए मैंने क्या
किया आप लोगों के लिए एक टेलीग्राम ग्रुप
बनाया है कि ये है आपका ग्रुप देखो यहां
पर तो इसका लिंक ऑलरेडी क्या है? हर एक
क्लास के जो सेक्शन है, हर एक क्लास का जो
डिस्क्रिप्शन है, डिस्क्रिप्शन में इस
ग्रुप का लिंक दिया गया है। यहां पर बहुत
सारे छोटे-छोटे टॉपिक मैं धीरे-धीरे बढ़ा
रहा हूं कि आपके अकॉर्डिंग आप उस टॉपिक पर
बात कर सकते हो उस टॉपिक पे। इसके लिए एक
डेकोरम मेंटेन करने के लिए मैंने पिन किया
हुआ है। डेकोरम ये है कि आप इसके अंदर
ज्वॉइ करोगे तो आप लोगों के लिए आप लोगों
से एक ही रिक्वेस्ट है कि बस फालतू की
चीजें नहीं होनी चाहिए। बिल्कुल काम की
चीजें चीजें होनी चाहिए। रिसोर्सेज मैं
शेयर करूंगा और डाउट्स में आप डाउट पूछ
सकते हो। तो आप लोग इसमें क्या कर सकते
हो? जॉइ कर सकते हो और आप अपने डाउट पूछ
सकते हो। बाकी अननेसेसरी की चीजें इसमें
एंटरटेन नहीं की जाएगी। अगर कोई अननेसेसरी
की चीजें शेयर करने की कोशिश भी करेगा तो
मैं उसको डायरेक्टली ब्लॉक कर दूंगा और
स्टूडेंट को दोबारा इसमें एक्सेस नहीं
दिया जाएगा। तो ये था ग्रुप की कहानी। मैं
इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं। तो चलिए फिर सेशन
को कंटिन्यू करें। करें सेशन को कंटिन्यू।
चलो
तो फिर से मैं बता देता हूं कि हम कहां पर
थे और क्या करने वाले थे और थोड़ा सा हिंट
दे देता हूं अगर कोई आज नया आया तो क्लास
में। देखो हमारा सिनेरियो क्या था कि एज ए
अटैकर एज ए पेंटेस्ट हमने क्या किया? एक
मिलेशियस माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड फाइल को
डिजाइन किया। डिजाइन करने के बाद हमने
किसी भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक के थ्रू
किसके पास भेज दिया? आपके टारगेट मशीन के
पास भेज दिया। टारगेट यूजर के पास गया।
यूजर ने जैसे ही उसका टाइटल देखा, उस फाइल
को देखा, यूजर ने उस पर डबल क्लिक किया।
डबल क्लिक करने के बाद उसने इनेबल कंटेंट
वाले बटन पर भी क्लिक कर दिया। और जैसे ही
यूजर क्या करता है कि इनेबल कंटेंट पर
क्लिक करता है सेम टाइम आपका जो वीबीए कोड
है सेम टाइम आपका जो मिलसियस मैक कोड है
वो एग्जीक्यूट होता है और सबसे पहले वो
क्या करता है इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग
करता है मतलब उस जो इंफॉर्मेशन हमें चाहिए
उस मशीन से उस इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या करता है
चुराता है चुराने के बाद क्या करता है
डायरेक्ट जो आपके अटैकर मशीन है उसके पास
क्या करता है उस इंफॉर्मेशन को भेज देता
है तो इस सिनेरियो को हम प्रैक्टिकली
परफॉर्म करने वाले
तो ये सारी चीज हम डिस्कस कर चुके थे।
स्टेप वन में क्या रहेगा? स्टेप थ्री में
क्या रहेगा? स्टेप फोर में क्या रहेगा?
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग कैसे परफॉर्म की
जाएगी? ये और स्टेप फाइव में क्या रहेगा?
ये सारी चीजें मैं पहले डिस्कस कर चुका
हूं। मैं इस पे आज रिपीट नहीं करने वाला।
आप प्रीवियस क्लास को देख सकते हो। तो
हम क्या कर रहे थे? हम स्टेप थ्री पे काम
कर रहे थे। जो प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
पे हमने काम किया था। स्टेप थ्री। ओके?
सिनेरियो आपको पता है कि सिनेरियो मैंने
क्या लिया था कि एक सीनियर टेक्निकल
रिक्रूटर था रिक्रूटर है ग्लोबल बैंक
कॉरपोरेशन में उनके जो कंपनी है कंपनी में
हायरिंग चल रही थी किसकी लीड एंटरप्राइज
क्लाउड आर्किटेक्चर की तो उसके अकॉर्डिंग
मैंने क्या किया अपना टेंपलेट डिजाइन किया
और टेंपलेट डिजाइन करके मैं प्रीक्स्ट
डिजाइन किया मैंने प्रीक्स्ट डिजाइन किया
है किसका एक
किसका एक रिज्यूे
लीड सिक्योरिटी लीडरशिप के लिए हमने हमने
क्या किया है? जो जिसकी रिक्वायरमेंट है
उस रिक्वायरमेंट के अकॉर्डिंग हमने एक
रिज्यूुमे तैयार किया है। तो रिज्यूुमे
हमने जो तैयार किया था ये हमने किया था।
सबको पता है कि ये रिज्यूुमे कैसा है? अगर
आपकी फर्स्ट क्लास है तो प्लीज आई
रिक्वेस्ट आप प्रीवियस क्लास को 100%
देखना क्योंकि ये प्रैक्टिकली हमने
परफॉर्म किया था। इसमें काफी टाइम स्पेंड
हुआ था हमारा क्योंकि हमने इसको प्रोफेशनल
बनाना था। क्योंकि आपको दिखने में ये
रिज्यूुमे नहीं दिख रहा होगा। ये एक आपको
वार्निंग दिखाई दे रही होगी। लेकिन
हालांकि इसके नीचे रिज्यूुमे लिखा हुआ है
जो आपको दिखाई नहीं दे रहा होगा। ओके ये
आपको दिखाई नहीं दे रहा होगा क्योंकि हमने
इसको हाइड कर रखा है। तो जो हमारा स्टेप
बच गया था हमें क्या करना था? इस फाइल को
सेव करना था। तो हमें क्या करना है? सेव
एज पर जाना था और इस फाइल का हमें क्या
नाम रखना था? हम रखते ग्लोबल
बैंक
ग्लोबल बैंक अंडरs
फाइल का नाम किसी ने सोचा था या नहीं सोचा
था? बताओ। ग्लोबल बैंक अंडरस्कोर कैंडिडेट
कैंडिडेट। ठीक है। उसके बाद प्रोफाइल
प्रोफाइल उसके बाद हम क्या कर दिया? इतना
कर दिया। देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं?
हमारे पास दो ऑप्शन है सेलेक्ट करने का।
मै इनेबल डॉट डॉक एम में भी सेव कर सकते
हैं। दूसरा जो मोस्ट फेमस हम मोस्ट कॉमनली
यूज करने वाले हैं। वर्ल्ड 97 200 ये तो
डॉट डॉक वाला हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। तो
डॉट DC एम में क्या है कि आप ये करके
देखना खुद से आपको पता चल जाएगा कि इन
दोनों में डिफरेंस है। तो मैं यहां पे
इसको सेलेक्ट करता हूं। और इसको मैं अपने
कहां पर सेलेक्ट कॉपी कर रहा हूं? इसको
मैं कॉपी कर रहा हूं अपने डॉक्यूमेंट्स के
अंदर। ठीक है? डॉक्यूमेंट्स के अंदर मैं
इसको कॉपी कर रहा हूं और सेव कर दिया।
यह मेरा डॉक्यूमेंट सेव हो चुका है। ओके
तो देखो ग्लोबल कैंडिडेट प्रोफाइल ये हमने
कॉपी अभी ये मेरी फिजिकल मशीन है जिस पे
मैं आपको बना रहा हूं। ये ये जो रिज्यूे
है या जो मिशियस पेलोड मैं अपनी फिजिकल
मशीन पर बना रहा हूं। बट प्रैक्टिकल शो
करने के लिए मेरे पास मशीन है। काली लin
का भी यूज़ करेंगे हम और अपने Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का भी हम यूज़ करने वाले
हैं। तो आई होप यहां तक सबको पता होगा।
उसके बाद हमें क्या करना है? उसके बाद
हमें क्या करना है? हमें वीवी एडिटर के
ऊपर जाना है। तो डेवलपर मोड में जाएंगे।
अब की बार हम नया तरीका यूज़ करेंगे। हम
पहले मैक्रोस पर जाते थे। अभी हम मैक्रोस
पर नहीं जाएंगे। हम जाएंगे विजुअल बेसिक्स
के ऊपर। यहां पर यहां पर क्लिक किया तो ये
आपके प्रोजेक्ट खुल गया। कौन सा प्रोजेक्ट
आपका? ग्लोबल बैंक। ये इस तरीके से। यहां
पर आपको जाना है दिस डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर।
और दिस डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर जाने के बाद
आपको डबल क्लिक करना है। जैसे आपने क्या
किया? इस पर डबल क्लिक किया तो यहां पर
आपको एक विंडो दिखाई देगी। इस विंडो को
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं? थोड़ी सी बड़ी विंडो
बना देता हूं ताकि आपको क्लियर क्लेरिटी
मिले कोड हम किस तरीके से लिख रहे हैं। तो
अभी हम कोड को लिखते हैं। तो सबसे पहले
मैं अभी अपना जो मिलिशियस कोड है उसके
डेवलपमेंट की शुरुआत करता हूं।
फंडामेंटल्स आपको अच्छे से समझा चुका हूं।
उसके उसमें कोई भी दो राय नहीं है। तो
सबसे पहले हम कोड लिखेंगे ऑप्शन
एक्सप्लसिट
एक्सप्लसिट डी एक्स पी एल आई सी आई टी ओपन
एक्सप्लसिट अभी मैंने ये क्यों यूज़ किया
सबसे पहले मैंने ये क्यों यूज़ किया ऑप्शन
एक्सप्लसिट देखो ये एक सेफ्टी रूल है मतलब
मतलब यह है कि जब आप अपने कोड में सबसे
पहले यह मेंशन करते हो ऑप्शन एक्सप्लसिट
इसका मतलब क्या है कि अब आप अपने कोड में
कोई भी वेरिएबल यूज़ करना चाहते हो तो उस
वेरिएबल को डिक्लेअ करना पड़ेगा डम कीवर्ड
की हेल्प से। ठीक है? अगर आप अपने कोड में
ऑप्शन एक्सप्लसिट का यूज़ करते हो तो इसका
मतलब है कि अगर मुझे अपने कोड में कोई भी
वेरिएबल यूज़ करना है तो सबसे पहले मुझे
उसको क्या करना पड़ेगा? डिक्लेअ करना
पड़ेगा। अब इससे फायदा क्या होगा? इससे
फायदा होगा कि आपकी जो कॉमन मिस्टेक्स
होती है खास करके आपके स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक्स
हैं वो कम होंगी। दूसरा क्या है? मेमोरी
बग्स होते हैं उनके भी चांसेस क्या है? कम
हो जाते हैं। इसलिए हम सेफ्टी के लिए क्या
करते हैं? इसको यूज करने वाले हैं।
भाई एक भाई मुझसे पूछ रहे हैं कि सर मेरे
पीसी पर लinक्स इन वीएम क्यों नहीं चलता?
आपका पेस्ट्री मुझे कैसे पता होगा यार?
ठीक है? उसके बाद देखो अभी हम एक कमेंट
मेंशन करते हैं। तो चलो कमेंट कैसे मेंशन
करते हैं? तो कमेंट को मेंशन कर लेते हैं।
चलो यहां पर हम कमेंट लिखेंगे। गुड। कमेंट
के अंदर हम क्या लिखने वाले हैं? हम मेंशन
कर रहे हैं
रेड टीम
स्टेजर।
हम एक रेड टीम स्टेजर बना रहे हैं। ठीक
है? किसके लिए? रिकॉन एंड
एंड
नेटवर्क एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
उसके ये एक और कंटिन्यू इसको थोड़ा
प्रोफेशनलिज्म मेंटेन करने के लिए सबको
दिखाई दे रहा है ना स्क्रीन पर ज़ूम कर
लेना क्योंकि इसमें ये ऑप्शन नहीं है ज़ूम
ज़ूम करने का ज़ूम कर लोगे सब लोग आप अपने
मोबाइल पर ज़ूम कर सकते हो। ओके?
मोबाइल पर अपनी स्क्रीन पर ज़ूम कर सकते
हो।
तो उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं? सबसे पहले
हम एक फंक्शन डिक्लेअ करेंगे। सबसे पहले
हम क्या करेंगे? एक फंक्शन बनाएंगे। हम
फंक्शन क्यों बनाएंगे? मैं आपको बता चुका
हूं कि हम हमारा फंक्शन का क्या रोल होता
है। तो सबसे पहले मैं क्या करता हूं?
प्राइवेट उसके बाद सब कीवर्ड एक फंक्शन
ओके सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
प्राइवेट
सब उसके बाद
ठीक है उसके बाद
प्राइवेट सब उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
इनिशियल
फंक्शन का नाम इनिशियल
फुल रिकॉन
फुल रिकॉन हम रखते हैं इनिशियल फुल
रिकॉर्न प्राइवेट इनिशियल फुल रिकॉन हम
फंक्शन का नाम रखते हैं आई होप ये नाम सही
रहेगा सब एग्री करते हैं उस इस नाम से
इनिशिएट
फुल रिकॉन आई एन आई टी ओके स्पेलिंग गलत
हो रही है
एन आई टी आई ए
टी ई इनिशिएट
फुल रिकॉर्ड
प्लीज कोई क्लास में जो भी प्रेजेंट है
इनको लिंक भेज दीजिए चैट में देखो ये मुझे
पसंद नहीं है देखो आप लोगों ने फिर से वही
काम कर दिया स्टूडेंट्स आए और आकर चले गए
स्टूडेंट्स आए और आकर चले गए फिर से मैं
लास्ट टाइम वाला काम करूंगा आप लोगों के
साथ और अगली बार मैं आपकी रिक्वेस्ट लूंगा
ही ठीक है? मैंने अभी एक फंक्शन क्रिएट
किया। उसके बाद नेक्स्ट।
ओके।
अभी भी कोई नहीं आया सर। कोई दिक्कत नहीं।
आप लोगों का इलाज मैं करूंगा। अच्छे से
करूंगा ना। मैं भी आप लोगों को धोखा दूंगा
ऐसे टाइम पर। तो उसके बाद हम क्या करते
हैं? वेरिएबल क्रिएट करते हैं। पहला
वेरिएबल हम क्रिएट करेंगे
ऑब सेल। ऑब्जेक्ट सेल एच ऑब्जेक्ट
पहला वेरिएबल हमने ये क्रिएट किया। ये
पहला वेरिएबल किसके लिए हम क्रिएट कर रहे
हैं? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट के लिए।
अब दूसरा वेरिएबल हम क्रिएट कर रहे हैं
किसके लिए? फाइल सिस्टम इंटरेक्शन के लिए।
एफएसओ
एज ऑब्जेक्ट। दूसरा वेरिएबल हम किसके लिए
क्रिएट कर रहे हैं? फाइल सिस्टम इंटरेक्शन
के लिए एक और वेरिएबल हम क्रिएट कर रहे
हैं जिसके अंदर हम क्या करेंगे? अपनी
टेंपरेरी जो रिपोर्ट है जहां पर हम क्या
कर रहे हैं? जो टीएक्सटी फाइल है टीxt
फाइल के अंदर हम क्या करेंगे? अपना जो
रिकॉन है जो हमारा हार्वेस्टेड डेटा है
उसको स्टोर करेंगे। ट जो आपका विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर हम कहां पर स्टोर करेंगे?
टेम फोल्डर के अंदर एक फाइल के अंदर। तो
उसका एक पाथ हम कहां पर मेंशन करेंगे?
उसका जो फुल पाथ है ना हम उसको एक वेरिएबल
के अंदर स्टोर करेंगे। तो उसके लिए हम एक
वेरिएबल रखते हैं हम टेम रिपोर्ट
टेम रिपोर्ट। ठीक है? टेम रिपोर्ट
एज स्ट्रिंग।
ठीक है? ये हो गया। नेक्स्ट एक और वेरिएबल
मैं क्रिएट कर रहा हूं। यह तो मेरा मेरा
वेरिएबल हो गया टेंपरेरी फाइल स्टोरेज पाथ
के लिए। एक और वेरिएबल रिकॉर्ड क्रिएट कर
रहा हूं मैं किसके लिए? जिसके अंदर मैं
अभी नहीं मैं इनहीं को ही करता हूं। हां,
एक और वेरिएबल मैं क्रिएट कर रहा हूं।
किसके लिए? रिकॉन
सीएमडी
एज स्ट्रिंग जिसके अंदर मैं क्या करूंगा?
वो कमांड सेव करूंगा जिसके अंदर मेरा क्या
होगा? जिस कमांड के थ्रू मैं क्या करूंगा?
रिकॉर्ड करने वाला हूं। इनेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग करने वाला हूं। उसके लिए
वेरिएबल वेरिएबल मैंने पहले कितने चार
वेरिएबल हमने क्रिएट किए।
तो अभी उसके लिए हम क्या करेंगे? अभी
मैंने वेरिएबल क्रिएट कर लिया चार। तो
सबसे पहले मुझे क्या करना है?
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट को वो करना है।
यूज़ करना है। उसका एक ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट
करना है। इंस्टेंस क्रिएट करना है। तो हम
कैसे करेंगे? सेट का यूज़ करेंगे।
उसके बाद इक्वल। उसके कैसे करते हैं हम?
क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट
एंड यहां पर लिखेंगे यह रहा
w स्क्रिप्ट डॉट सेल
इस तरीके हमने क्या कर लिया एक
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का एक ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट
कर लिया बिकॉज़ क्योंकि हमें क्या करना है?
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ इंटरेक्ट करना है।
इसलिए हम डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का यूज़ करेंगे।
उसके बाद हम एक और ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट
करेंगे। किसका? फाइल सिस्टम इंटरेक्शन के
लिए। सब फाइल सिस्टम इंटरेक्शन के लिए एक
ऑब्जेक्ट और क्रिएट करेंगे।
क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट
इसके लिए हम यूज़ करते हैं
एस
सी आर आई ई
स्क्रिप्टिंग
डॉट मैं इसको समझा दूंगा। अभी एक्सप्लेन
कर दूंगा।
फाइल सिस्टम
सिस्टम ऑब्जेक्ट
ओबीj ऑब्जेक्ट यह रहा
यह रहा। अब ये क्या चीज है? मैंने आपको ये
कवर तो किया ही नहीं। स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट
फाइल सिस्टम ऑब्जेक्ट। स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट
फाइल सिस्टम ऑब्जेक्ट। मैंने ये तो कवर
किया नहीं। तो इसके लिए हम चलते हैं किसके
ऊपर?
चलो देखो। स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट फाइल सिस्टम
ऑब्जेक्ट क्या है? इसका यूज किया जाता है
आपका फाइल एंड फोल्डर मैनपुलेशन के लिए।
दिस ऑब्जेक्ट इज यूज्ड टू क्रिएट, रीड,
कॉपी, मूव, डिलीट, लोकल ड्राइव्स,
फोल्डर्स, फाइल्स ऑन योर सिस्टम। बेसिकली
आप क्या कर सकते हो? अगर आपको ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर फाइल सिस्टम के साथ
इंटरेक्शन करना है, तो उस केस में आपको
क्या करना है? इस ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़ करना
है। स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट फाइल सिस्टम
ऑब्जेक्ट। स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट फाइल सिस्टम
ऑब्जेक्ट। कहीं स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक ना हो।
इसलिए मैं क्या कर इसको कॉपी करके इधर
पेस्ट भी कर लेता हूं ताकि सब सही है।
गुड। तो इस पे फिर से चलते हैं। ये रहा।
तो अभी एग्जांपल लेते हैं। सेम हमने
क्रिएट किया हुआ है। इसका ऑब्जेक्ट कैसे
क्रिएट करते हैं? ऐसे क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट
स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट फाइल सिस्टम ऑब्जेक्ट।
इस तरीके से हम इसका ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट कर
सकते हैं। अगर आपको कोई क्या करना है? अगर
आपको कोई टेक्स्ट फाइल क्रिएट करनी है।
ठीक है? आपको कोई टेक्स्ट फाइल क्रिएट
करनी है तो आप यूज़ करोगे इस ऑब्जेक्ट का
नाम डॉट क्रिएट टेक्स्ट फाइल मेथड का यूज़
करोगे। किसका यूज़ करोगे आप? डॉट क्रिएट
टेक्स्ट फाइल मेथड का यूज़ करोगे। ठीक है?
डॉट क्रिएट टेक्स्ट फाइल मेथड का यूज़ करने
वाले हो। अब इसके अंदर आपको कितने
पैरामीटर देखने को मिल रहे हैं। इसके अंदर
आपको तीन पैराटर्स देखने को मिल रहे हैं।
तो तीनों पैरामीटर्स की वैल्यू मैं आपको
समझा देता हूं कि किसका क्या मतलब है। ठीक
है? ये तीनों पैरामीटर्स की जो वैल्यू है
मैं आपको समझा देता हूं। जस्ट अ सेकंड
वेयर आई राइट डाउन। ओके यस। तो सबसे पहला
जो पैरामीटर है इसमें आप मेंशन करते हो
किसका? फाइल पाथ मेंशन करते हो। जिस पर आप
जिस फाइल पाथ पर आपको क्या करना है? फाइल
क्रिएट करनी है। दूसरे में क्या है? यहां
पर आप बुलियन वैल्यू मेंशन करते हो। ट्रू
या फाल्स? ट्रू का मतलब क्या है? कि अगर
आप ट्रू या फाल्स? मतलब अगर आपको पहले से
मतलब अगर फाइल पहले से क्या है एग्जिस्ट
करती है क्या उसको ओवराइट करना है या नहीं
करना है वो इस बेस पे डिसाइड किया जाता
है। दूसरा क्या है? थर्ड वन क्या है आपका?
यहां पर भी आप यू ये यूनिकोड वाले में भी
क्या है? बुलियन वैल्यू देते हो। अगर ट्रू
है तो यूटीएफ 16 यूनिकोड का यूज़ किया
जाएगा। यूनिकोड का यूज़ किया था। अगर फॉल्स
छोड़ देते हो डिफॉल्ट तो ये किसका यूज़
करेगा? आस्का आई टू का यूज़ करेगा। उसके
बाद अगर आपको ये चेक करना है कि जो आपका
फाइल सिस्टम है किसी फाइल को एकिस्टिंग
टेक्स्ट फाइल को आपको क्या करना है? सर्च
करना है। तो ऐसे कर सकते हो। एफएसओ मतलब
ये इसका ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट ओपन टेक्स्ट फाइल।
यहां पर आपको उस फाइल का फुल पाथ मेंशन
करोगे। उसके बाद आप क्या करते हो? नेक्स्ट
में आप मेंशन करते हो फाइल मोड। यहां पर
क्या मेंशन करते हो? फाइल मोड। वन का मतलब
क्या है? ओनली रीडिंग। टू का मतलब राइटिंग
के लिए। मतलब अगर आपको सिर्फ रीड करना है
तो वन यूज़ करोगे। यहां पर अगर यहां पर
आपको ओवराइट करना है तो टू यूज़ करोगे। या
आपको अपेंड करना है तो यहां पर वैल्यू का
आप यूज़ करोगे एट। तीन वैल्यू यूज़ कर सकते
हो। वन, टू और एट। वन का मतलब रीड ओनली।
टू का मतलब ओवराइट। थ्री का मतलब आपको
अपेंड करना है। थर्ड जो आप ऑप्शन यहां पर
यूज़ कर सकते हो वो आपका बुनियल वैल्यू है।
मतलब यहां पर क्या है? अगर फाइल अवेलेबल
नहीं है। ठीक है? अगर फाइल अवेलेबल नहीं
है तो क्या करना है मुझे? वो फाइल क्रिएट
करनी है या क्रिएट नहीं करनी। ट्रू है तो
ये क्रिएट करेगा। फॉल्स है तो ये आपको एक
एरर देगा। फाइल नॉट फाउंड एरर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जो लास्ट है i फॉर्मेट यहां पर आप इंटीजर
वैल्यू मेंशन करते हो यहां पर तीन वैल्यू
मेंशन कर सकते हो आप -2
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
-1 0 -2 यूज़ करेगा डिफॉल्ट स्ट्रिंग का
यूज़ करेगा -1 का मतलब यूनिकोड की तरह उसको
ओपन करेगा या जीरो का मतलब क्या है आपका
डिफॉल्ट है आस्का टू में उसको ओपन करेगा
थर्ड वन क्या है आप यूज़ कर सकते हो क्रिएट
फोल्डर ये तो फाइल के केस में आप इसका यूज़
कर सकते हो ऑब्जेक्ट अगर आपको कोई फोल्डर
क्रिएट करना है तो आप क्या यूज़ कर सकते
हो? इसका यूज़ कर सकते हो क्रिएट फोल्डर
का। अगर आपको कोई फोल्डर के अंदर कोई फाइल
एग्जिस्ट करनी है, एग्जिस्ट करती है या
नहीं करती है वो चेक करना है तो यहां पे
ऐसे चेक कर सकते हो। फोल्डर एक्सिस्ट करता
है तो ये ऐसे चेक कर सकते हो। अगर आपको
डिलीट करना है तो डिलीट मेथड यूज़ कर सकते
हो। कॉपी करना है तो कॉपी मेथड यूज़ कर
सकते हो। मूव करना है मूव मेथड का यूज़ कर
सकते हो। फोल्डर को डिलीट करना है तो
डिलीट फोल्डर मेथड का यूज़ कर सकते हो।
फोल्डर को कॉपी करना है तो कॉपी फोल्डर का
यूज कर सकते हो। मूव फोल्डर का यूज कर
सकते हो। ऐसे तो सारे तो हमें अभी काम के
है नहीं। तो हमें इतना आईडिया मिल गया कि
अगर मुझे वीबीए के अंदर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
के अंदर वीबीए की हेल्प से ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर फाइल सिस्टम के साथ
इंटरेक्ट करना है। उसके साथ कोई फाइल रीड
करनी है, वहां पर कोई फाइल क्रिएट करनी
है, डिलीट करनी है, तो मुझे किसका यूज़
करना पड़ेगा? इस ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा। उस ऑब्जेक्ट का नाम क्या है? आपका
स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट फाइल सिस्टम ऑब्जेक्ट।
आई होप ये चीज सबको समझ में आ गई। तो हमने
यहां पर क्या किया? उसी का एक ऑब्जेक्ट
क्रिएट किया फाइल सिस्टम का। नेक्स्ट अब
मैं यहां पर क्या करने वाला हूं? नेक्स्ट
हम यहां पर करने वाले हैं। जस्ट वेट वेट
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट ओके
नेक्स्ट हम क्या करने? अब पाथ स्टोर
करेंगे। हम टेम रिपोर्ट
टेम रिपोर्ट इक्वल इसके अंदर हम यूज़ करने
वाले हैं। अभी हम यहां पर हम फुल पाथ
स्टोर करेंगे। जहां पर वो जो हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हार्वेस्टिंग कर
रहे हैं। इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हार्वेस्टिंग के
लिए हमें क्या करना चाहिए? एक फाइल चाहिए
जहां पर हम क्या करेंगे? उस इनेशन स्टोर
करेंगे। तो फाइल जहां पर उस जिस फाइल के
अंदर इनफार्मेशन स्टोर होगी। मतलब वो फाइल
क्या होगी? अगर एग्जिस्ट करती है तो ठीक
है नहीं तो उसको क्रिएट कर दिया जाएगा। तो
उसका फुल पाथ यहां पर मेंशन किया जाएगा।
तो देखो उसके लिए हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं ओबीj
सेल
इसके अंदर आपका विंडोस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
को यूज़ करने वाले हैं। डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
सेल को यूज़ करने वाले हैं। उसके बाद डॉट
एक यहां पर एक क्या है? आपका एक मेथड है।
वो मेथड कौन सा है? मैं आपको लिखता हूं।
एक्सपेंड
आई
एक्सपेंड एनवायरमेंट ओके स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक
हो तो मेरे को प्लीज चैट में बता दे
एक्सपेंड
एनवायरमेंट स्ट्रिंग्स एक मेथड है ये रहा
स्ट्रिंग्स ये आपका मेथड है। इसके अंदर
हमने क्या मेंशन किया है देखो परसेंटेज टी
ई एम पी परसेंटेज यह क्या है आपको पता चल
जाएगा उसके बाद हम यहां पर लिखते हैं हम
सिस्टम
अंडरस्कोर
ऑडिट अंडरस्कोर
रिपोर्ट
डॉट txt
ओके और इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं बेसिकली
जो
एक्सपेंड एनवायरमेंट स्ट्रिंग्स है। ये
मेथड क्या करता है? ये मेथड जो एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल्स होते हैं। किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स होते
हैं जिसके अंदर वैल्यू स्टोर की जाती है।
तो ऐसे ही एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल होता है
आपका टईएमपी।
ठीक है? टीईएमपी विंडोज के अंदर। तो
टीएमपी एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स में क्या है
कि जो आपका जो सिस्टम पाथ है क्योंकि मुझे
क्या करना है? मुझे जो वैल्यू स्टोर करनी
है, मुझे जो फाइल स्टोर करनी है, वो
टेंपरेरी पाथ पर स्टोर करनी है। अब मुझे
नहीं पता कि जो पर्टिकुलर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
है, उसका टेम फुल फुल पाथ क्या है?
टेंपरेरी। तो इसलिए मुझे क्या किया कि वो
रन टाइम पर ही क्या करे? टेम वेरिएबल से
उस वैल्यू को रीड करे और रीड करके यहां पर
पेस्ट कर सकते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल अगर आप
देखना चाहो तो कैसे बन सकता है यहां पर?
यहां पर अगर आप देखना चाहो तो इसके ओके
वेट वेट वेट
व्हाई इज इट कंपाइलेशन एरर
एक्सपेंड आई एन
हम हम
स्ट्रिंग्स ओके वेट वेट
यहां पर हमने क्या डबल कोट के अंदर देना
है। हमें यहां पर डबल कोट के अंदर मेंशन
करना था। चलो तो बेसिकली यहां पर क्या है
कि आपका नॉर्मली पाथ क्या हो जाता है?
नॉर्मली पाथ क्या होता है? सी यूजर
यूजरनेम ऐप डेटा लोकल टेम सिस्टम ऑडिट इस
टाइप से ये बेसिकली आपको यहां पे लिख देता
हूं। मैं कमेंट में लिख देता हूं। देखो
ठीक है? यहां पर आपके लिए मैं कमेंट में
लिख देता हूं।
आपका क्या होगा?
टेम फोल्डर का पाथ क्या होगा आपका?
फोल्डर का पाथ। ठीक है? नॉर्मली क्या होता
है? नॉर्मली पाथ यह होगा आपका कि अह सी
ड्राइव यह इस तरीके से इस तरीके से रहता
है। यूज़र्स उसके बाद यूजरनेम
उसके बाद
ऐप डाटा उसके बाद लोकल
Windows के अंदर यही होता है। लोकल लोकल
के बाद टीईएमपी ये रहता है आपका टेम टेम
फोल्डर। ठीक है? टेंपरेरी फोल्डर पाथ तो
यही रहता है ना? अब हमने क्या किया? हमने
लिखा परसेंटेज टेम। यह ऑटोमेटिकली इस पाथ
को क्या करेगा? उठाएगा। उठाकर इसकी जगह पर
लिख देगा। और हमारा फुल पाथ क्या बन
जाएगा? हमारा टेम फोल्डर का फुल पाथ बन
जाएगा।
फुल पाथ मेरा क्या बनेगा? ये बनेगा। ठीक
है? ये रहा। यह मेरा फुल पाथ बन जाएगा।
कंट्रोल सी यहां पर हम कंट्रोल वी उसके
बाद यहां पर यह रहा सिस्टम।
ऑडिट अंडर
रिपोर्ट डॉट txt
ये फुल पाथ बन जाएगा अंडरस्टुड तो यहां पर
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं टेम रिपोर्ट वेरिएबल
के अंदर ये फुल पाथ है ना ये यहां पर मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं एज ए रेफरेंस सेव कर रहा
हूं एज ए रेफरेंस
एज ए रेफरेंस क्या कर रहा हूं इसको सेव कर
रहा हूं
अंडरस्टुड? यहां तक सबको क्लियर है कि
हमने क्या किया? पहले हमने
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट को क्रिएट
किया। उसके बाद हमने फाइल इंटरेक्शन के
लिए एक ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट किया। उसके बाद
हमने क्या किया कि जिस लोकेशन पर हमने उस
फाइल को जो हार्वेस्टेड इनेशन को स्टोर कर
रहा है उसका फुल पाथ हमने यहां पर क्या कर
दिया? मेंशन कर दिया।
ब्रदर आपको इसलिए समझ में नहीं आ रहा
क्योंकि आज आप फर्स्ट टाइम आए हो क्लास
में इसलिए आपको समझ में नहीं आ रहा।
अदरवाइज आपको कुछ प्रीवियस क्लासेस से
इसको पढ़ते हैं खास करके क्लास 60 से तो
आपको आसानी से समझ में आ जाता है कि यह चल
क्या रहा है। कुछ भी हार्ड एंड फास्ट नहीं
है। ठीक है? कुछ भी हार्ड एंड फास्ट नहीं
है। तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है। तो हम
चलते हैं अभी स्लाइड के ऊपर। अभी हम चलते
हैं स्लाइड के ऊपर। यहां तक तो हमने क्या
कर लिया?
पाथ स्टोर कर लिया। नेक्स्ट जो हमारा
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है जो नेक्स्ट
स्टेप आता है स्टेप फोर। स्टेप थ्री हमने
सेटअप कर लिया। उसके बाद हमने थोड़ी सी
स्क्रिप्टिंग लिख ली। कुछ वेरिएबल्स बना
लिए। उसके बाद हमने डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट कर लिया। उसके बाद फोल्डर
का रिफरेंस या जो फुल पाथ था जहां पर फाइल
आपकी सेव होगी उसका एक पाथ हमने क्या कर
दिया? वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर कर लिया। अभी
बात आती है हमारी इसकी
कि स्टेप फोर हमें कैसे अभी हमें क्या
करना है? स्टेप फोर परफॉर्म करना है।
प्रैक्टिकली हमें क्या करना है? स्टेप फोर
को क्या करना है? यहां पर डिजाइन करना है
कि स्टेप फोर क्या था? जैसे ही यूजर डबल
क्लिक करेगा, डबल क्लिक करते ही वो इनेबल
कंटेंट करें और इनेबल कंटेंट क्लिक करते
ही आपका क्या करें? माइक्रो कोड रन हो और
सिस्टम इनेशन, नेटवर्क डिटेल, इंस्टॉल
सॉफ्टवेयर डिटेल्स ये सारी डिटेल्स क्या
करें? आपको हार्वेस्ट होकर, कलेक्ट होकर
आपके सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्ट के अंदर क्या हो
जाए? स्टोर हो जाए। ये सारा हमें क्या
करना है? प्रैक्टिकली डिजाइन करना है। ये
सारा का सारा हमने क्या करना है?
प्रैक्टिकली डिजाइन करना है और यहां पर
स्टोर हो जाए। तो इसको हम कैसे
प्रैक्टिकली डिजाइन करेंगे? बेसिकली हमें
मुझे क्या करना है? अब इस चीज को डिजाइन
करने के लिए मुझे कुछ तो चाहिए ना। मुझे
क्या करना है? Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
लिए क्या चाहिए? मुझे क्या करना है? इनेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग करनी है। उसके लिए मुझे
कमांड्स चाहिए। जिनका यूज़ करके मैं क्या
करूंगा? Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से इनेशन
निकालूंगा। बेसिकली मुझे क्या करने? क्या
चाहिए? कमांड लाइन इंस्ट्रक्शंस चाहिए।
मेरा ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या है? सिस्टम
इंफॉर्मेशन को कलेक्ट करना, नेटवर्क डिटेल
को कलेक्ट करना, सॉफ्टवेयर के डिटेल
कलेक्ट करना, यूजर से ग्रुप की इंफॉर्मेशन
कलेक्ट करना। अभी मेरा प्राइमरी टारगेट
है। इस प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन में मेरा
प्राइमरी टारगेट यही है। बट मेरा फिर से
सवाल यह है कि ये मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं?
इसके लिए मुझे जरूरत पड़ेगी कमांड प्र्ट
की। Windows कमांड प्र्प की cmd.exc
की तो
सीएमडी का यूज़ कर मैं इस तरीके से यूज़ कर
सकता हूं। कैसे cmdexc
नेक्स्ट हफन सी नवलप फॉरवर्ड स्लश सी फिर
कमांड लाइन वन कमांड लाइन टू कमांड लाइन
थ्री कमांड लाइन फोर अप टू कमांड लाइन एन
क्योंकि जो काम मैं करना चाहता हूं वो काम
मेरा एक कमांड से तो नहीं हो सकता।
उसके लिए मुझे जरूरत पड़ने वाली है
मल्टीपल कमांड्स की और मल्टीपल कमांड्स को
मुझे क्या करवाना है? एक ही बार में रन
करवाना है। तो उसके लिए मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा? उन मल्टीपल कमांड्स को आपस में
जोड़ना पड़ेगा। कॉनकटिनेट करना पड़ेगा। और
उनको जोड़कर एक ऐसी कमांड बनानी पड़ेगी।
एक ऐसा पेलोड बनाना पड़ेगा जिसकी हेल्प से
हम क्या करें? सिर्फ एक बार में ही वो
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर ले। इसीलिए
आपकी जो पेलोड की कमांड है यह रहेगी
सीएमडीxe ये आपका कमांड प्र्प है ये हाई
फसी इसका मतलब क्या होता है आई विल
एक्सप्लेन तो सबसे पहले हम समझते हैं कि
यहां कमांड लाइन वन टू थ्री के बीच में
हमने ये क्यों यूज़ किया है डबल एंड डबल
एमसेंट मतलब क्यों यूज़ किया है इसका यूज़
किया जाता है मल्टीपल कमांड्स को चेंज
करने के लिए मल्टीपल कमांड्स को आपस में
जोड़ने के लिए इसका यूज किया जाता है ये
क्या चीज है ये एक ऑपरेटर की तरह काम करता
है। कौन सा ऑपरेटर? लॉजिकल एंड ऑपरेटर।
लॉजिकल एंड ऑपरेटर की तरह काम करता है। ये
क्या करता है कि आपकी जो कमांड लाइन है,
आपका जो कमांड प्र्ट है, उसको इंस्ट्रक्शन
देता है कि भाई मैं यहां पर यूज़ हो रहा
हूं। तो मेरा मतलब ये है कि जो कमांड लाइन
वन है, जब तक ये ट्रू नहीं हो जाएगी तब तक
ये एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो जाएगी। जब तक यह
सक्सेसफुली रन नहीं हो जाएगी तब तक तब तक
कमांड लाइन टू कमांड लाइन थ्री कमांड लाइन
फोर यह एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो सकती। सेम
कंडीशन इसके लिए है। फिर ये हो गया। ओके
ये ट्रू हो गई तो फिर ये इस कमांड पे आ
गया। तो इस कमांड के लिए ये कंडीशन डिसाइड
कर रहा है कि ओके जब तक कमांड लाइन
सक्सेसफुली रन नहीं हो जाएगी तब तक कमांड
लाइन थ्री एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर सकती।
बेसिकली इसने क्या किया? सारी कमांड्स को
आपस में चेंज कर दिया और चेंज करके एक
कमांड बना दिया। उसके बाद इनका जो भी
आउटपुट आएगा उसको हम डायरेक्टली किस में
क्या करेंगे? सेव करेंगे उस टेंपरेरी फाइल
के अंदर सेव करेंगे। उस टेंपरेरी फाइल के
अंदर हम क्या करेंगे? उसको सेव करने वाले
हैं। तो इसलिए cmd डॉट exc
ये क्या करता है? इट इंस्ट्रक्ट द विंडोज
कमांड प्र्ट टू लॉन्च एग्जीक्यूट द
प्रोवाइडेड कमांड स्ट्रिग एंड ऑटोमेटिकली
टर्मिनेट द कमांड विंडो वंस एग्जीक्यूशन
इज फिनिश्ड। बेसिकली हमने मल्टीपल कमांड्स
को आपस में चेंज कर दिया। और ये कमांड
क्या बोलती है? Windows कमांड प्र्ट को
बैकग्राउंड में इन सारी कमांड्स को रन
करो। ओपन करो यूजर को बिना बताए और जब
आपका काम खत्म हो जाए। काम खत्म होने के
बाद चुपचाप ऑटोमेटिकली कमांड प्र्प्ट को
भी बंद कर दो। किसी को बताना मत। मतलब
सारा काम चुपचाप करना है। किसी को बताना
नहीं है। बैकग्राउंड में कमांड प्र्ट को
ओपन करना है। जो मल्टीपल कमांड्स मैंने
आपको चेंज किया है उनको एग्जीक्यूट करना
है और उसको एक उसका आउटपुट एक फाइल में
स्टोर करना है और कमांड प्र्ट को बंद कर
दो। यूजर को नहीं बताना है। यूजर को नहीं
बताना है। अंडरस्टुड?
अंडरस्टुड कि हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
मल्टीपल कमांड्स को चेंज करने वाले हैं।
क्योंकि हमें सिस्टम इनेशन क्रैक करनी है।
नेटवर्क की डिटेल्स चाहिए। हमें यूज़र्स की
इनेशन चाहिए। हमें इंस्टॉल सॉफ्टवेयर्स की
इनेशन चाहिए। ये सारी चीजें हमें चाहिए।
उसके लिए हमें क्या करना है? तो हमारा
फाइनल पेलोड क्या है? यह है एक्चुअल पेलोड
यह है जो हम इस कोड के अंदर यूज करने वाले
हैं। एक्चुअल पे पेलोड कौन सा है? यह है
जिसको हम एक वेरिएबल में स्टोर करने वाले
हैं। अभी मैं जानता हूं कि आपको ये अभी
समझ में नहीं आ रहा होगा। किसी को समझ में
आ रहा है कि ये पेलोड आपको समझ में आ रहा
होगा कि ये पेलोड एक्चुअल में क्या है।
यही वो पेलोड है जो आपको आपके लिए
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग करेगा।
हां अभिषेक मेरा नेक्स्ट फोकस वही है लगभग
मैक्सिमम।
चलो मैं इसको समझा देता हूं। तो सबसे पहले
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं यहां पर ये चीज
डबल को्स के अंदर पूरा पेलोड दिखाई दे रहा
होगा।
मैंने डबल कोड्स के अंदर वो सीएमडी cmdex
वाला पूरा पेलोड जो यहां पर यहां पर
क्लियर दिखाई नहीं दे रहा। ठीक है?
आपको क्लियर दिखाई नहीं दे रहा। तो ये डबल
कोट्स के अंदर क्यों है? तो यहां पर डबल
कोट्स का मतलब समझते हैं कि डबल कोट्स का
मतलब ये है कि अगर आपको अभी वीबीए की बात
हो रही है। तो अगर आपको वीबीए में कोई भी
प्लेन टेक्स्ट या कोई भी स्ट्रिंग लिखनी
है तो उसको क्या करना है आपको? डबल कोट के
अंदर रखना पड़ेगा। अगर आपको कोई स्ट्रिंग
आउट मतलब आपको कोई स्ट्रिंग रिटर्न करनी
है, कोई आपको
टेक्स्ट किसी को भेजना है तो आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा? वीबीए के अंदर उस पूरी
वैल्यू को डबल कोट के अंदर रखना पड़ेगा।
अब हमारी रिक्वायरमेंट क्या है? हमारी
रिक्वायरमेंट है कि जो cmdexc है हफन सी
कमांड लाइन वन कमांड लाइन टू कमांड लाइन 3
कमांड लाइन फोर एंड कमांड लाइन अप टू एन
और उसको उसका आउटपुट एक फाइल में सेव हो
जाए ये पूरा का पूरा जैसे कि ये दिख रहा
है ना आपको ये रहा ये पूरा का पूरा एज इट
इज किसके अंदर क्या हो जाए आपके
सीएमडी के अंदर एग्जीक्यूट हो जाए। यह
हमारी रिक्वायरमेंट है। हमारी
रिक्वायरमेंट यह है कि भैया जो यहां का
कमांड मैंने लिखी है, जो पेलोड मैंने आपके
लिए डिजाइन किया है चेंज करके मल्टीपल
कमांड्स का वो एज इट इज कमांड प्र्प के
अंदर एग्जीक्यूट हो जाए। अगर वो एज इट इज़
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना है तो हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा? उसको स्ट्रिंग बनाकर रखना पड़ेगा
इसके अंदर मैक के अंदर वीबीए के अंदर।
इसीलिए हमने क्या किया? उसको डबल कोट के
अंदर सेव किया है। मतलब यह पूरा पेलोड है
ना एज इट इज क्या करेगा? आपके सीएमडी पर
एग्जीक्यूट होगा। चाहे उसमें कोई कॉमा आए,
उसके अंदर कोई फॉरवर्ड स्लैश आए, बैक
स्लैश आए, उसके अंदर एमसैंड आए, डबल कोट
आए, सिंगल कोट आए, कुछ भी आए वो एज इट इज
उठाकर आपके कमांड प्रो पे क्या कर दिया
जाएगा? एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया जाएगा। यह
हमारी रिक्वायरमेंट है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
तो इसीलिए जब डबल कोट यूज किया जाता है
मतलब सॉरी डबल कोट का यूज किया जाएगा तो
जो कंपाइलर होता है वो कंपाइलर क्या करता
है उसको एग्जीक्यूट करने की बजाय उसको
रिकॉग्नाइज करता है उसको समझता है कि जो
पूरा कंटेंट है वो एक स्ट्रिंग है एक
टेक्स्ट कंटेंट है मुझे उसको एग्जीक्यूट
नहीं करना है मुझे उसको एज इट इज़ किसी को
देना है मुझे एज इट इज़ उसको किसी को देना
है इसीलिए ठीक है तो पेलोड का छोटा सा
हिस्सा तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। उसके
बाद यह है वो पूरा पेलोड।
हम क्या चाहते हैं? यह जो पूरा पेलोड है,
यह कितना बड़ा पेलोड है। इतना बड़ा पेलोड
है। अभी इतना बड़ा पेलोड यहां पर आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है। ये तो हमारा पेलोड
है। एक कमांड लाइन वन कमांड लाइन टू कमांड
लाइन थ्री कमांड लाइन फोर कमांड लाइन फाइव
कमांड लाइन सिक्स कमांड लाइन से कमांड
लाइन 8 कमांड लाइन 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18
कमांड्स का हमारा एक ये तो जो छोटा सा
डेमो 18 कमांड्स का हमारा एक पेलोड बना
हुआ है और उन सबको चेंज किया हुआ है। तो
अभी सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज क्या है कि अगर इस
पूरे पेलोड को मैं सिंगल लाइन में लिखूं
ईबी के अंदर तो क्या होगा? आपको उसको
पढ़ना मुश्किल हो जाएगा। तो इसीलिए हम
क्या करेंगे? मल्टी लाइन टेक्निक का यूज
करेंगे।
हम उसके लिए मल्टी लाइन टेक्निक का यूज
करेंगे। तो इसीलिए आपको यहां पर बार-बार
दो चीजें दिखाई दे रही होंगी। एम परसेंट
अंडरस्कोर एम परसेंट अंडरस्कोर एमसेंट
अंडरस्कोर एम परसेंट हर लाइन के पीछे आपको
ये दिखाई दे रहा होगा। इसका मतलब क्या है?
इसमें दो चीजें हैं। पहला तो एम परसेंट
दूसरा है अंडरस्कोर। तो पहला जो एमसेंट है
उसका मतलब है कंकटिनेशन।
जो एंड ऑपरेटर है उसका मतलब है कंकटिनेशन।
यह क्या करता है? ये दो स्ट्रिंग्स को आपस
में जोड़ने का काम करता है। फॉर एग्जांपल
जो ये पहली स्ट्रिंग है और इसके बाद में
क्या एक वाली स्ट्रिंग है। इन दोनों को
जोड़ने का काम करता है। जैसे नीचे दिख रहा
है आपको स्ट्रिंग वन यहां तक ये आपका यहां
तक आपका स्ट्रिंग वन है। ठीक है? और इसके
बाद यह आपकी स्ट्रिंग टू है। तो इन दोनों
स्ट्रिंग्स को आपस में जोड़ने का काम कौन
करता है? यह एमपरसेंट।
ठीक है? आपस में कनकने कंकटिनेशन करने का
मतलब कि भैया यह इसी का हिस्सा है। अलग
नहीं है। ठीक है? कंकटिनेशन का काम यही
है। एंड ऑपरेटर का काम यही है। उसके बाद
मैंने ये अंडरस्कोर क्यों यूज़ किया है?
अंडरस्कोर क्या है? कंटीन्यूएशन के लिए।
जो अंडरस्कोर है यह आपके वीबी एडिटर को यह
बताता है कि भैया जो कोड खत्म नहीं हुआ है
आप समझ रहे हो कि यहां पर cmd डॉट exc
और उसके बाद सिंगल ब्रैकेट तो यहां पर कोड
खत्म नहीं हुआ है। इसके
इसके बाद भी जो कोड है वो जो अगली लाइन
में जो कोड लिखा हुआ है जैसे लाइन नंबर टू
लाइन नंबर थ्री लाइन नंबर फोर में जो कोड
लिखा है वो इसी का पार्ट है।
भैया मेरे तुरंत बाद जो इको वाला कोड लिखा
वो इसी का ही हिस्सा है।
एमपरसेस ने बोला कि ओके यह कंटिन्यू करना
है। दो स्ट्रिंग को आपस में जोड़ना है। ये
उसी का पार्ट है। लेकिन जो अंडरस्कोर बता
रहा है कि जो आप सोच रहे हो कि मेरे आगे
कुछ नहीं है। नहीं नीचे जो कोड लिखा है वो
भी इसी का हिस्सा है। ठीक है? वो भी इसी
का हिस्सा है। वो भी इसी का हिस्सा है।
इसलिए हमने यहां पे यूज़ किया है कंकटिनेशन
एंड अंडरस्कोर।
इसीलिए हमने यहां पर यूज किया है
कंकटिनेशन एंड अंडर स्कोर। समझ में आ गया?
जब हमने इन दोनों को यूज किया तो इसने
क्या किया? एंड ने कि दो स्ट्रिंग्स को
आपस में जोड़ दिया। एंड अंडरस्कोर ने बोला
कि जो नेक्स्ट लाइन में कोड लिखा है वो भी
इसी का ही हिस्सा है। यहां पर आपका जो कोड
है वो खत्म नहीं हुआ है। जब अंडरस्कोर आना
बंद हो जाएगा तब मेरा कोड कंप्लीट हो गया।
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? पेलोड क्लियर है?
यहां तक क्लियर है? सबसे पहले डबल कोट
क्यों यूज किया? उसके बाद एमपर सेट और
अंडरस्कोर क्यों यूज किया जा रहा है उस
पेड के अंदर? क्योंकि देखो यह पेलोड था
हमारा एक्चुअल एक्चुअल पेलोड ये है। तो
यहां पर देखोगे आप ध्यान से यहां पर
देखो डबल कोट उसके बाद देखोगे हर हर लाइन
के पीछे ये दिखाई दे रहा है आपको। हर लाइन
के पीछे ये क्यों है भाई ये? उसका कारण
वही है। और हर लाइन में डबल कोट है। हर
लाइन में डबल कोट है। तो ये इसी का कारण
है। तो आई होप यह समझ में आ गया होगा।
नेक्स्ट
उसके बाद नीचे लिखा है एक रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर का यूज़ किया है। जैसा कि सबको पता
है रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर का काम क्या होता
है? कि जो भी आउटपुट जनरेट हुआ है उस
पर्टिकुलर कमांड से उसको क्या करना है?
इसके बाद जो पाथ मैंने प्रोवाइड किया है,
इसके बाद जो फाइल मैंने प्रोवाइड की है,
उसके अंदर स्टोर करना है। उसके अंदर स्टोर
करना है। अब उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया?
मैंने ट्रिपल कोट का यूज किया है। यहां पर
ट्रिपल कोटेशन का यूज किया है। उसके बाद
एंड एंड का मतलब वही है। जोड़ना उसके बाद
वेरिएबल का नाम उसके बाद एम परसेंट उसके
बाद ट्रिपल कोट फिर एक और डबल कोट। डबल
कोट क्या है? वो पीछे वाला स्टॉप हो रहा
है। तो मैंने क्या किया है कि ट्रिपल कोट
का क्यों यूज़ किया?
देखो ट्रिपल कोट का तभी यूज़ किया। ट्रिपल
डबल कोट सॉरी ट्रिपल डबल कोट का तभी यूज़
किया जाता है खासकर जब आपको क्या करना हो
कि कोई स्ट्रिंग है कोई वैल्यू है जिसके
अंदर डबल कोट यूज़ हो रहा हो अब हमारी तो
क्या है ऑब्वियसली ये हमारा पाथ है डबल
कोट के अंदर हमारा पाथ है जो पास होगा
किसको कमांड लाइन को ठीक है कमांड लाइन
क्या करती है रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर के बाद
फुल पाथ के लिए डबल कोट में स्ट्रिंग
स्टोर करती है या वैल्यू स्टोर करती है तो
ये फुल पाथ पास हो रहा है तो हमारे हमारे
पास क्या है? डबल कोट है। इसीलिए हमने
क्या किया? ट्रिपल डबल कोट का यूज़ किया
ताकि उसके अंदर जो वैल्यू है डबल कोट के
अंदर वो सेफ रहे।
उसके अंदर जो वैल्यू है वो सेफ रहे।
अंडरस्टुड? तो आपको पूरा पेलोड क्लियर हो
गया?
पूरा पेलोड क्लियर हो गया? पूरा पूरा
पेलोड समझ में आ गया सबको? तो इस पेड को
हम क्या करते हैं? के बाद मैं यहां से
कॉपी करता हूं और इसको पेस्ट कर देता हूं
कि भैया लो यह हमारा पेलोड रहा। ठीक है?
रिकॉन सीएमडी ये हमारा है पेलोड।
कंट्रोल
सी और मैं चलता हूं किसके अंदर? ये रहा।
तो इसके बाद हम पे पेस्ट कर देते हैं
किसको? अपने पेलोड को।
और पेलोड से पहले हम लिखते हैं कमेंट। तो
भैया कमेंट लिख देते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। चलो कमेंट लिखना
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो हमारा काम
ही है थोड़ा प्रोफेशनल बनाने के लिए।
नेक्स्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग।
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग साइलेंटली।
चलो यह भी हमने लिख दिया। मैच कर देते हैं
थोड़ा प्रोफेशनल लगे। तो यहां पर हम क्या
कर रहे हैं? पेलोड को पेस्ट कर दिया।
पेलोड को हमने पेस्ट कर दिया और एक बार
देखते हैं कि सब कुछ सही तो है। ऐसा कुछ
तो नहीं कि हमने कुछ यहां पर गड़बड़ कर दी
हो। सही है। रिकॉन सीएमडी अभी यहां पर
वेरिएबल को यूज किया। उसके अंदर पूरा
सीएमडी.xc
अंडर एकको ये डेट एंड टाइम कंप्यूटर नेम
यूजर डोमेन यूजर नेम ओके यहां से आप
सिस्टम इनेशन निकाल लोगे। यहां पर नेटवर्क
डिटेल निकाल लोगे। यहां पर यूज़र्स की
डिटेल निकल जाएगी। यहां पर आपके इंस्टॉल्ड
प्रोग्राम्स की डिटेल्स निकल जाएगी। तो
हमारा पेलोड एग्जैक्टली सही है। तो हमने
पेलोड क्या है? सही से डिजाइन किया है।
सही से हमने पेलोड को डिजाइन कर लिया है।
उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
नेक्स्ट लाइन ऑफ कोड हम क्या यूज़ करने
वाले हैं?
ये रहा।
नेक्स्ट लाइन ऑफ कोड क्या है? हमें इसको
रन करवाना है। रन कैसे करवा सकते हैं?
इसको रन कैसे करवाएंगे?
किसी को कोई आईडिया है इसको रन करवाने के
लिए। इसको रन करवाने के लिए हमें यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा
सेल डॉट रन मेथड का। उसके बाद हम मेंशन
करेंगे रिकॉन सीएमडी
ओके रिकॉन सीएमडी। मैं इसको कर देता हूं
थोड़ा सा अगले लाइन में ताकि आपको क्लिटी
रिकॉन सीएमडी कॉमा जीरो। अब जीरो के पावर
दिखाता हूं आपको। उसके बाद
ओके उसके बाद वेट वेट वेट यहां भी मेरी
गड़बड़ की है मैंने ये रहा उसके बाद हम क्या
करते हैं ट्रू
भाई वेट करो इसका एग्जीक्यूट होने का इसका
वेट करो तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है
तो यहां पर हमने क्या कर दिया इनेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग कर दी जैसे यहां तक मैं अगर
इसको रन करूंगा दूंगा तो इस यह सारी इनेशन
कलेक्ट होकर किस में अंदर चली जाएगी? उस
फाइल के अंदर सेव हो जाएगी। इस फाइल के
अंदर सेव हो जाएगी। अभी मुझे क्या करना
है? नेक्स्ट स्टेप। नेक्स्ट स्टेप मेरा
क्या है? एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन। सो नेक्स्ट
स्टेप भी तो मेरा क्या है? एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन।
नेटवर्क एक्सिल्ट्रेशन है ना नेक्स्ट
स्टेप मेरा। तो चलो फिर एक कमेंट मेंशन कर
देते हैं।
नेटवर्क एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
नेक्स्ट स्टेप मेरा क्या है? नेटवर्क एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन।
नेटवर्क एक्सिल्ट्रेशन एंड वाया हम लिख
लेंगे बाद में और नेटवर्क एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन
क्योंकि मैं आपको बताऊंगा कि हम किसके
थ्रू किसको लगता है किसके थ्रू करेंगे
नेटवर्क एक्सिल्ट्रेशन?
किसी को कोई आईडिया है?
चलो हम चलते हैं यहां तक। तो नेक्स्ट
स्टेप हमारा कौन सा है भैया?
स्टेप फाइव एक्स फिल्ट्रेटिंग हार्वेस्टेड
डेटा टू अटैकर मशीन। ये आपका स्टेप फाइव
है। तो चलिए ये भी समझ लेते हैं। तो स्टेप
फाइव में आपको क्या-क्या करना है? आपको
चार काम करने हैं। स्टेप फाइव में। सबसे
पहले क्या करना है आपको?
यह जो फाइल हमने क्रिएट की थी इंफॉर्मेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग स्टेप में स्टेप फोर में इस
फाइल से हमें क्या करना है? डाटा को रीड
करना है। दूसरा काम क्या करना है? अटैकर
मशीन के साथ कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश करना है।
तीसरा काम क्या करना है? इसके अंदर जो
डाटा कलेक्ट किया था उस डाटा को अटैकर
मशीन के ऊपर भेजना है। चौथा काम क्या करना
है? जब वह डाटा हमने एक बार अटैकर के पास
भेज दिया तो जो कनेक्शन हम इस्टैब्लिश
करेंगे उस कनेक्शन को क्लोज करना है।
क्लोज करने के बाद जो फाइल हमने डिलीट ये
फाइल जो हमने क्रिएट की थी इसको क्या करना
है भैया? डिलीट। सबूत नहीं छोड़ना। हम
इसको कर देंगे डिलीट।
तो चलिए फिर कैसे करेंगे? तो ये काम करने
के लिए
किसका यूज़ करेंगे हम? पावर सेल का यूज़
करेंगे। तो पावर सेल का यूज़ करेंगे। तो
पावर सेल की कौन सी कमांड यूज़ करने वाले
हैं हम? ये वाली पावर सेलXC नो प्रोफाइल
नॉन इंटक्टिव एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी बाईपास
विंडो स्टाइल हिडन एंड हफन कमांड और यहां
पर जो लिखा ना मैं ये रहा अगर मैं आपको
यहां पर एक काम कर देता हूं। ये इरेज करता
हूं पहले।
अरे भैया
आ जाओ।
यह रहा। मैं इसको इरोज कर देता हूं एक
बार। सो दैट यू कैन अंडरस्टैंड थोली। तो
यहां पर अभी हम क्या करेंगे? हमें चार
टास्क परफॉर्म करने हैं। जैसा कि हम
सीएमडी के साथ किया था वैसे ही पावर साल
के साथ करेंगे। चारों टास्क दो टास्क वन
से लेकर टास्क फोर तक हम कहां पर है? उसके
जो भी कमांड यूज़ होने वाली है, सारी कमांड
यहां पर मेंशन करेंगे। सारी कमांड हम क्या
कर रहे हैं? इसके अंदर मेंशन करेंगे। और
ये आगे फिक्स रहेगा। हाइपर नो प्रोफाइल
हाइपर नॉन इंटक्टिव एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी
बायपास विंडोज स्टाइल हिडन ताकि विंडो
स्टाइल हिडन का मतलब हिडन रहे यूजर को पता
नहीं होना चाहिए चुपचाप काम हो जाए या अभी
पावर सेल के बारे में ज्यादा मैं आपको
इसलिए नहीं पढ़ा रहा क्योंकि पावर सेल के
ऊपर भी मैं आपको क्लासेस लूंगा बिल्कुल
जीरो से पावर सेल भी पढ़ाऊंगा थोड़े से
लेवल तक ताकि आपको क्योंकि आपका जो
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन सेक्शन होगा उसमें
पावर सेल विंडज खासकर विंडज के केस में
पावर सेल्स ज्यादा यूज़ होती तो इसके बारे
में हम बाद में पढ़ेंगे। तो चलिए फिर चार
स्टेप परफॉर्म करने हैं। तो वो कौन-कौन सी
कमांड है जिनका हम यूज़ करेंगे अपने सारे
स्टेप्स परफॉर्म करने के लिए। तो सबसे
पहले बात करने हमें क्या करना है? इस फाइल
से डेटा को रीड करना है। इस फाइल से इस
लोकेशन से मुझे क्या करना है? डेटा को रीड
करना है। तो मैं रीड कैसे करूंगा? उसके
लिए मेरे पास होती गेट कम गेट कंटेंट
कमांड लेट का यूज़ करते हैं हम। गेट कंटेंट
हफन रो उसके बाद वो फुल पाथ मेंशन करेंगे
इस फाइल का। इस फाइल का फुल पाथ हम यहां
पर क्या करेंगे? मेंशन करेंगे। तो ये ये
कमांड लेट क्या करती है? गेट कंटेंट कमांड
लेट्स रीड द डेटा फ्रॉम द टारगेट फाइल।
जबकि जो हफन रो पैरामीटर है इंश्योर द
एंटायर फाइल कंटेंट कंटेंट्स इंक्लूडिंग
स्पेसिंग लेआउट लाइन ब्रेक आर प्रिजर्व एज
ए सिंगल कंटीन्यूअस स्ट्रिंग। कहने का
मतलब क्या है कि भैया कहने का मतलब यह है
कि जो आपकी गेट कंटेंट कमांड है जो कमांड
लेट्स है यह क्या करती है ये क्या करती है
कि इसकी हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो जो
आपके टारगेट फाइल है उसका सारा डेटा रीड
करो रीड कर सकते हो और रीड करके उस पूरे
डेटा को एक वेरिएबल में स्टोर कर सकते हो
ताकि उसको ट्रांसफर किया जा सके उस डाटा
को ट्रांसफर किया जा सके तो चलिए फिर
डाटा को ट्रांसफर करने के लिए हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा एक कनेक्शन क्रिएट करना
पड़ेगा। हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा? अटैकर
मशीन के साथ कनेक्शन बिल्ड करना पड़ेगा।
और अटैकर मशीन के साथ मैं कनेक्शन कैसे
बिल्ड कर सकता हूं? इसकी हेल्प से सिस्टम
नेटp
क्लाइंट ये IPपी एड्रेस एंड पोर्ट नंबर IP
एड्रेस एंड पोर्ट नंबर और आपको ये अभी तक
नहीं समझ में आ रहा होगा तो भैया मैं इसको
समझा देता हूं।
पावर सेल ऑपरेट ऑन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट डॉट नेट
फ्रेमवर्क मतलब जो आपकी पावर सेल है पावर
सेल microsoft के डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क पर
काम करती है और जब कोई चीज डॉट नेट
फ्रेमवर्क पे काम करती है तो ऑटोमेटिकली
बाय डिफॉल्ट उसकी जो पावर है वो बहुत
ज्यादा बढ़ जाती है। तो इसीलिए पावर सेल
किस पे काम करती है? डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क के
ऊपर। तो इसलिए बाय डिफॉल्ट जो पावर सेल है
उसके पास पहले से ही बहुत ही ज्यादा
पावरफुल क्लासेस है। जिनमें से एक क्लास
कौन सी है आपकी? सिस्टम डॉट नेट डॉट सॉकेट
नेम स्पेस। बहुत जिसको हम क्लास के बजाय
लाइब्रेरी भी बोल सकते हैं। बहुत सारी
पावरफुल लाइब्रेरीज है। उनमें से एक
पावरफुल लाइब्रेरी आपकी है। सिस्टम डॉट
नेट डॉट सॉकेट नेम स्पेस या लाइब्रेरी। ये
लाइब्रेरी करती क्या है? दिस लाइब्रेरी इज
डिज़ फॉर लो लेवल नेटवर्क प्रोग्रामिंग। जो
लाइब्रेरी है इसका यूज किया जाता है लो
लेवल नेटवर्क कम्युनिकेशन के लिए। अगर
आपको किसी के साथ कम्युनिकेट करना है तो
इस लाइब्रेरी का आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। ठीक
है? और इस लाइब्रेरी के अंदर एक क्लास
होती है जिसका नाम है टीसीp क्लाइंट
क्लास। ये क्या करती है? जो आपका क्लाइंट
है क्लाइंट के साथ टीसीपी कनेक्शन क्रिएट
करती है इस्टैब्लिश करती है। बेसिकली यह
लाइब्रेरी है। लाइब्रेरी के अंदर एक
स्पेशल क्लास है जिसका नाम टीसीपी क्लाइंट
क्लास है। सेम नाम है। ठीक है? वो क्या
करती है? जो क्लाइंट है उस क्लाइंट के साथ
क्या करती है? कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश करती
है। कौन सा? टीसीपी कनेक्शन। अब इससे
फायदा क्या हुआ इस क्लास से? इस क्लास से
फायदा यह हुआ कि हमें बार-बार
जो नेटवर्किंग कोड है उसको जीरो से नहीं
लिखना पड़ता। हम जस्ट इन क्लास का यूज कर
सकते हैं और आसानी से अपना कनेक्शन
एस्टैब्लिश करते हैं। अदरवाइज इस टाइप की
क्लासेस नहीं रहती तो हमें पूरा
नेटवर्किंग कोड जो इसमें लिखा वो ज़ीरो से
हर बार लिखना पड़ता। लेकिन हमें हर बार
लिखने की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि ऑलरेडी
डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क ने इस तरह की क्लासेस
दी हुई है। अब जब क्लास दी हुई है और पीसी
पे कनेक्शन बना सकती है तो इसके अंदर दो
पैराटर्स भी है। जैसे पैरामीटर वन और
पैरामीटर टू। तो आप सबको पता है कनेक्शन
एस्टैब्लिश करने के लिए दो चीजों की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। दो इंपॉर्टेंट
कंपोनेंट्स की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। वो
कंपोनेंट्स कौन-कौन से हैं? पहला कंपोनेंट
आपका आईपी एड्रेस, दूसरा कंपोनेंट आपका
पोर्ट नंबर। तो सेम यहां पर भी क्या है कि
इस लाइब्रेरी के अंदर जो क्लास यूज़ की जा
रही है, उसको दो पैराटर्स की रिक्वायरमेंट
है। वो दो पैराटर्स कौन से हैं? आपके आईपी
एड्रेस एंड पोर्ट नंबर।
अब यह क्या करती है यह क्लास
जब यह जो सिस्टम नेटp
क्लाइंट जब नाम की जो क्लास है लाइब्रेरी
है जो क्लास है वो जब वो एग्जीक्यूट होती
है तो सबसे पहले वो क्या करती है थ्री वे
हैंडशक परफॉर्म करती है सबसे पहले थ्री वे
हैंडशक परफॉर्म करती है वेरीफाई करती है
एक कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश करती है एक वर्चुअल
कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश करती है थ्री वे
हैंडशक करती है ओके जब आपका थ्री वे
हैंडशक कंप्लीट हो जाता है। बेसिकली क्या
हो गया?
बेसिकली आप उसका कोड कैसे लिखोगे? इस
तरीके से लिखोगे।
इस तरीके का कोड आप लिख सकते हो थ्री वे
हैंडशक के लिए या जो कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
करने के लिए आप कैसे कोड लिखोगे? न्यू
ऑब्जेक्ट सिस्टम नेट डॉट सॉकेट टीसीp
क्लाइंट IPपी एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर बेसिकली
जब आप यह ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट करोगे और इसका
जो रेफरेंस वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर करोगे
तो इस स्टेज पे क्या होगा वी आर
यूटिलाइजिंग द सिस्टम डॉट नेट डॉट सॉकेट
डॉट टीcp क्लास टू एस्टैब्लिश ए न्यू
टीसीp नेटवर्क कनेक्शन विद ए रिमोट मशीन
मतलब इसका मतलब क्या है कि जब आप इसको
अपने कोड में यूज़ करोगे इसका मतलब क्या है
कि आप एक नया टीसीपी कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
कर रहे हो किसी एक रिमोट मशीन के साथ
जिसका आईपी एड्रेस और पोर्ट नंबर आपने
यहां पर प्रोवाइड किया है। अंडरस्टुड?
अंडरस्टुड कि नेटवर्क कनेक्शन कैसे
इस्टैब्लिश होगा। दो कमांड बता दी कि फाइल
रीड करने के लिए कौन सी कमांड का यूज
करोगे और नेटवर्क कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश करने
के लिए आप कौन सी कमांड का यूज करने वाले
हो। अंडरस्टुड गाइस?
अंडरस्टुड?
समझ में आ गया? चलिए
अब बात आते हैं। बात आती है कि आपने
कनेक्शन तो इस्टैब्लिश कर लिया। आपने
कनेक्शन तो इस्टैब्लिश कर लिया लेकिन उस
कनेक्शन पर डेटा भेजने के लिए आपको डेटा
ट्रांसफर करने के लिए हमें स्ट्रीम की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। मतलब वंस ए सॉकेट
एस्टैब्लिश ए कनेक्शन बिटवीन टू
कंप्यूटरटर्स ए नेटवर्क स्ट्रीम इज
रिक्वायर्ड टू फैसिलिटेट डेटा ट्रांसफर।
मतलब वही है कि आपने कनेक्शन बना लिया।
लेकिन उस कनेक्शन के ऊपर डाटा ट्रांसफर
करने के लिए आपको स्ट्रीम की रिक्वायर्ड
किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट होती है? स्ट्रीम की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। किसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट? फिर से बता देता हूं मैं
आपको। किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट? स्ट्रीम की
जरूरत पड़ती है। अब ये स्ट्रीम क्या है?
ये मैं आपको समझाता हूं। जैसे आपको एक
पिक्चर दिखाई दे रही होगी। आप स्ट्रीम को
आप सॉकेट को समझ सकते हो। एक पाइप लाइन
है। एक पाइप लाइन है जिसके अंदर क्या है?
वाटर फ्लो होता है। ठीक है? तो उस पाइप
लाइन के जो एंड्स है अगर मुझे किसी और
पाइप लाइन के साथ जोड़ना है तो बीच में
किसका यूज़ करूंगा? मैं वाल्व का यूज़
करूंगा। तो वो वाल्व आप समझ सकते हो
सॉकेट। अगर इस साइड भी मुझे इसको किसी के
साथ कनेक्ट करना है तो मैं किसका यूज़
करूंगा? वाल्व का यूज़ करूंगा। उस वाल्व को
हम क्या समझ सकते हैं? सॉकेट। तो सॉकेट
आपकी क्या है? वॉल की तरह है। ये ठीक है?
आपके जो वाल्व है उसी की तरह आपकी सॉकेट
भी है। जैसे यहां पर देख सकते हो आपका जो
वाल की तरह आपकी क्या है? सॉकेट है। तो
अभी यहां पर क्या है? टारगेट मशीन विंडोज
है। इधर अटैकर मशीन है। तो इनके साथ मुझे
कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश करना है। तो दोनों
साइड हमारी क्या है? सॉकेट क्रिएट होनी
चाहिए। ठीक है? सबसे पहले सॉकेट क्रिएट
होती है। उसके बाद आपका कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट होता है। अभी सॉकेट तो क्रिएट हो
गई। कनेक्शन बन गया। क्योंकि जो पाइप लाइन
थी इसको हमने कनेक्ट कर दिया। पाइप लाइन
कनेक्ट होने के बाद इसके अंदर जो वाटर
फ्लो करेगा एक्चुअल वाटर फ्लो। इसके अंदर
जो पानी बहेगा ठीक है? वो क्या है? आपका
स्ट्रीम होगा। तो यहां पर बात उसी की हो
रही है कि भैया आपने सॉकेट इस्टैब्लिश कर
लिया। आपने कनेक्शन बना लिया। पाइप लाइन
से वाल्व को जोड़ा और अभी इसके अंदर पानी
जा सकता है। हमने वो कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश
कर लिया। लेकिन अभी हमें पानी को भी तो
भेजना पड़ेगा। तो सेम
सेम यहीं पर वही है कि वो पानी भेजने के
लिए या वो डाटा ट्रांसफर करने के लिए हमें
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है स्ट्रीम की। ठीक है?
अभी तो यहां पर वही है ए सॉकेट क्रिएट द
कम्युनिकेशन चैनल एंड स्ट्रीम एक्ट एस द
एक्चुअल मीडियम थ्रू व्हिच रो बाइट्स ऑफ
डेटा ट्रेवल अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क। इसका मतलब
क्या है? कि एक जगह से दूसरी जगह डेटा
नेटवर्क के अंदर डेटा ट्रेवल करने के लिए
या जो रॉ बाइट्स ऑफ डेटा आपको भेजनी है,
उसके लिए हम किसका यूज़ करते हैं? स्ट्रीम
का यूज़ कर सकते हैं। उसके लिए हम किसका
यूज़ करते हैं? स्ट्रीम का यूज करते हैं।
अंडरस्टुड कि आपको सॉकेट और स्ट्रीम के
अंदर जो डिफरेंस है वो समझ में आ गया
होगा। सॉकेट और स्ट्रीम के बीच में जो भी
डिफरेंस हो शायद आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
नहीं आया तो मुझे बताओ।
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
वेरी गुड। अगर यहां तक सबको क्लियर है तो
अगला सवाल यह आता है कि वह हम क्रिएट कैसे
कर सकते हैं? तो अगर आपको स्ट्रीम क्रिएट
करने हैं तो आप यूज करोगे सॉकेट डॉट गेट
स्ट्रीम मेथड का। सॉकेट डॉट गेट स्ट्रीम
मेथड का यूज़ करोगे और इस मेथड की हेल्प से
आप क्या कर सकते हो? स्ट्रीम क्रिएट कर
सकते हो। जिसके अंदर आपका डेटा फ्लो
करेगा, ट्रांसफर होगा। और उसको हमने क्या
कर दिया? एक डॉलर स्ट्रीम का मतलब क्या
है? कि जो डॉलर सिंबल यूज़ किया जाता है
वेरिएबल के लिए। किसके अंदर? पावर सेल के
अंदर। तो पावर सेल के अंदर हमने एक
वेरिएबल क्रिएट किया। उसके अंदर इसका
रेफरेंस स्टोर कर दिया। स्ट्रीम का
कनेक्शन यहां पर इस्टैब्लिश हो गया। यहां
पर हमने क्या कर दिया? उसका स्ट्रीम का
क्या कर दिया? स्ट्रीम हमने सेटअप
कॉन्फ़िगर कर दिया। चलो भैया, हमने स्ट्रीम
भी कॉन्फ़िगर कर लिया। अब जब हमने स्ट्रीम
कॉन्फ़िगर कर दिया, तो अब एक टेक्निकल
चैलेंज है। और टेक्निकल चैलेंज क्या है?
कि जो स्ट्रीम है स्ट्रीम के अंदर ओनली
बाइट्स डाटा ट्रांसफर न्यूममेरिक डाटा ही
क्या होता है ट्रेवल करता है ट्रांसफर
होता है
जो आपका जो स्ट्रीम है उसके अंदर आपका जो
डेटा है डेटा टाइप कौन सा ट्रेवल होता है
बाइट्स मतलब न्यूममेरिक डेटा बट मेरे पास
डेटा कौन सा है फाइल में मेरे पास डेटा
कौन सा है टेक्स्ट या स्ट्रिंग फॉर्मेट
में डेटा है ये तो समस्या हो गई स्ट्रिंग
हमने क्रिएट कर ली कनेक्शन क्शन हमने बना
लिया। डेटा ट्रेवल करवाना है। डेटा
ट्रांसफर करना है। लेकिन डेटा ट्रांसफर सब
कौन सा हो सकता है? न्यूमेरिक डेटा। और जो
मेरे पास जो डेटा है वो कौन सा है? वो
टीएक्सटी फॉर्मेट में डेटा है। टेक्स्ट
डेटा या स्ट्रिंग फॉर्मेट में डेटा है। तो
मुझे इसके लिए एक ट्रांसलेटर की जरूरत
पड़ेगी। एक हेल्पर की जरूरत पड़ेगी जो
क्या क्या काम करेगी? जो मेरा जो टेक्स्ट
या जो स्ट्रिंग डेटा है वो आपके बाय डेटा
में कन्वर्ट करें या जो नेटवर्क कनेक्शन
है उसके रिक्वायरमेंट के हिसाब से जो
नेटवर्क स्ट्रीम है उसकी रिक्वायरमेंट के
हिसाब से डेटा को कन्वर्ट करें। तो उसके
लिए भैया हम यूज़ करते हैं सिस्टम डॉट
स्ट्रीम राइटर। ये क्या करता है? इट इज़
कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड डायरेक्टली ऑन द टॉप ऑफ द
स्ट्रीम। जब आपने स्ट्रीम क्रिएट की इसके
ऊपर हम कॉन्फ़िगर करते हैं किसको? इसको इस
ट्रांसलेटर को क्या करते हैं? कॉन्फ़िगर
करते हैं। और यह ट्रांसलेटर क्या करता है?
यह ट्रांसलेटर जो टेक्स्ट डेटा है उसको
नेटवर्क स्ट्रीम के अकॉर्डिंग बाइट में
कन्वर्ट करके क्या कर देता है? उसको
नेटवर्क कनेक्शन के ऊपर पुश कर देता है।
तो हमारी प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व होगी। हमें क्या
चाहिए? एक मीडियम चाहिए। एक ट्रांसलेटर
चाहिए। और ट्रांसलेट मैं कैसे यूज़ कर सकता
हूं? ये सिस्टम डॉट आया डॉट स्ट्रीम
राइटर। तो चलो फिर ये कैसे मैं डिजाइन कर
सकता हूं? इसको कॉन्फ़िगर कैसे कर सकता
हूं? इसको कॉन्फ़िगर करूंगा मैं इस तरीके
से। यहां पर मैंने कॉन्फ़िगर कर लिया। और
इसके अंदर एक मेथड होता है। क्फ़िगर कर
लिया। इसका एक ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट कर लिया।
बट मुझे डेटा को क्या करना है? अभी भेजना
है। कन्वर्ट करने से काम नहीं चलेगा। उस
डेटा को मुझे भेजना भी है। तो, उसके लिए
हम एक मेथड यूज़ होता है डॉट राइट मेथड।
डॉट राइट मेथड। यहां पर जो डॉलर कंटेंट
मैंने यूज़ किया है, इसके अंदर क्या
रेफरेंस आपका? वो फुल पाथ है। किसका? आपके
फाइल का रेफरेंस का। इसका फुल पाथ है। तो
दिस मेथड टेक्स द कंप्लीट फाइल डेटा
स्टर्ड विद इन द डॉलर कंटेंट वेरिएबल एंड
राइट इट डायरेक्टली इनू द स्ट्रीम डेटा
बफर। मतलब ये क्या करता है कि ये मेथड जो
डॉलर कंटेंट वेरिएबल था मतलब ये जो कंटेंट
वेरिएबल है इसके अंदर जो पाथ है जो फाइल
है जो इसका अंदर जो डेटा स्टोर किया गया
फाइल वाला उस डेटा को क्या करता है?
स्ट्रीम के बफर में पुश कर देता है।
स्ट्रीम के बफर में उसको डाल देता है।
चलिए फिर अब जो डाटा हमारा कहां पर आ गया?
स्ट्रीम बफर के अंदर। नेक्स्ट क्या हो
गया? जब आपने क्या कर दिया? डॉट राइट मेथड
की हेल्प से उस डेटा को राइट कर दिया बफर
के अंदर। तो उसके बाद आता है डॉट प्लस
मेथड। डॉट प्लस मेथड। क्योंकि डेटा तो
राइट हो गया स्ट्रीम बफर के अंदर। लेकिन
परफॉर्मेंस के लिए परफॉर्मेंस
ऑप्टिमाइजेशन के लिए क्या होता है कि जो
वो डेटा है वो कुछ समय के लिए मेमोरी में
रहता है। वो डेटा कुछ फ्रिक्शन ऑफ सेकंड
या कुछ फ्रिक्शन ऑफ टाइम के लिए वो क्या
रहता है? मेमोरी में रहता है। तो डॉट प्लस
मेथड क्या करता है? डॉट प्लस मेथड ये
इंश्योर करता है कि बफर में एक भी नॉट
सिंगल बाइट ऑफ डेटा ना बचे। उसको जबरदस्ती
करके तुरंत नेटवर्क पर ट्रांसमिट कर दिया
जाए। ट्रस नेटवर्क पर वो ट्रांसमिट हो
जाए। बेसिकली क्या है कि वो डाटा बफर में
कुछ फ्रिक्शन सेटिंग के लिए सेकंड के लिए
रुक रहा है। लेकिन इस चीज की इंश्योरिटी
इस चीज को इंश्योर क्या कर रहा है? ये
मेथड इंश्योर कर रहा है कि भाई कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। अगर आपका जो डेटा है वो बफर में
रुक भी रहा है तो मैं उसको जबरदस्ती करके
हर एक डेटा को मैं क्या कर दूंगा? नेटवर्क
पर ट्रांसफर कर दूंगा। और जब मैं एक बार
नेटवर्क पे डेटा को ट्रांसफर कर दूंगा।
ठीक है? जब मैं एक बार नेटवर्क पर डाटा को
ट्रांसफर कर दूंगा। उसके बाद मैं क्या
करूंगा? उसके बाद इस मेथड की हेल्प से हम
क्या कर देंगे? कनेक्शन को टर्मिनेट कर
देंगे। जब एक बार आपका डेटा ट्रांसफर हो
गया। उसके बाद डॉट क्लोज मेथड की हेल्प से
क्या किया आपने? इस कनेक्शन को टर्मिनेट
कर दिया। और फाइल को डिलीट तो हम बाद में
कर देंगे। कनेक्शन हमने टर्मिनेट कर दिया।
मेरा काम हो गया। मुझे डाटा मिल गया। मुझे
इस कनेक्शन की नॉट रिक्वायरमेंट। उसके बाद
फिर हमने क्या कर दिया? सॉकेट डॉट क्लच भी
कर देंगे। यह आपका कंप्लीट पेलोड है। यह
आपका कंप्लीट पेलोड है। यहां पर कितनी
कमांड यूज़ हुई? कमांड वन,
कमांड टू,
कमांड थ्री, कमांड फोर, कमांड फाइव, कमांड
सिक्स। इस तरीके से आपने यूज़ की है। तो ये
आपका कंप्लीट पेलोड है पावर सेल का। पावर
सेल का पेलोड सबको क्लियर है?
पावर सेल का पेलोड क्लियर है तो चलो हम
इसको लिख देते हैं। लिखें फिर कोड के अंदर
चलो फिर हम इसको लिख देते हैं। यहां से
मैं इसको पेलोड को कॉपी कर लेता हूं
क्योंकि मेरा पेलोड ये रहा। मेरा पेलोड ये
रहा और मैं पूरा पेलोड कॉपी करता हूं अभी।
चलिए तो इस पेड को भी हम क्या करते हैं?
अभी कॉपी करके यहां लिख देते हैं। और यहां
पर कंट्रोल वी पेस्ट कर दिया। अभी उससे
पहले मैंने एक इफ स्टेटमेंट का यूज़ किया
है। इफ एफएसओ
फाइल एकिस्ट।
सबसे पहले मैं क्या करूंगा कि हमने क्या
किया था? हमने पहले एक फाइल क्रिएट की।
फाइल टीxt फाइल क्रिएट की। उसके अंदर डेटा
स्टोर किया। तो मैं डायरेक्टली अपना ये
नहीं कर सकता ना कि मैं मुझे क्या करना
है? डाटा ट्रांसफर करना है। मुझे चार
स्टेप परफॉर्म करने हैं। डेटा को रीड करना
है। कनेक्शन बनाना है। डेटा को ट्रांसफर
करना है। कनेक्शन टर्मिनेट करना है। फाइल
को डिलीट करना है। तो सबसे पहले मैं ये भी
तो चेक करूंगा ना कि फाइल एक्सिस्ट करती
है भी नहीं करती। अगर फाइल एक्सिस्ट ही
नहीं करती तो मैं इस कोड को खामखा क्यों
चलाऊं? क्यों कनेक्शन करूं फालतू में? बात
यही है ना? तो इसीलिए क्या किया हमने?
सबसे पहले इफ कंडीशन लगाई। इफ कंडीशन
लगाने के बाद यहां पे एक चेक लगाया। अगर
फाइल एक्सिस्ट करती है तभी मेरा क्या होगा
जो यह था पूरा पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट करेगा।
पूरा पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट करेगा। ठीक है? अभी
मुझे मैं दो वेरिएबल मैंने अभी तक क्रिएट
नहीं किए हैं। एक तो अटैकर का आईपी के लिए
और दूसरा अटैकर के पोर्ट के लिए। तो चलो
मैं दो वेरिएबल और क्रिएट कर लेता हूं
यहां पर। दो नहीं एक और वेरिएबल और क्रिएट
करना पड़ेगा। ये वाला। सबसे पहले इसके लिए
भी मुझे एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट करना है। तो
चलो फिर हम सबसे पहले वेरिएबल क्रिएट कर
लेते हैं अपना टास्क परफॉर्म करने के लिए।
तो सबसे पहला वेरिएबल क्रिएट करेंगे ये
वाला
डम
पीS एक्स फिल्ट्रेट कमांड एच इसमें भी
मुझे स्ट्रिंग ही स्टोर करनी है। स्ट्रिंग
मैंने ये कर लिया। ओके ये उसके बाद मुझे
क्या करना है? अटैकर आईपी तो चलो भैया
मुझे सेम आई अभी क्या करूं? मैं हार्ड
कोडेड करूंगा लेकिन बट इधर नहीं करूंगा
मैं। चलो फिर डम अटैकर आईपी एच ए स्ट्रिंग
ऑब्वियसली
अटैकर आईपी के लिए भी यहां पर मैं
स्ट्रिंग मेंशन कर दूंगा। उसके बाद अटैकर
पोर्ट उसको मैं क्या कर रहा हूं? अटैकर
पोर्ट। चलो इट कंट्रोल वी और यहां पर हम
मेंशन करते हैं
बीम वेरिएबल अटैकर पोर्ट और
एक और वेरिएबल डिफाइंड कर दिया हमने और
सारे वेरिएबल हमने यूज़ भी कर लिए स्ट्रिंग
अभी मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा उनकी वैल्यू भी
तो स्टोर करनी पड़ेगी ना और मुझे क्या है
काली इन का आईपी एड्रेस सपोर्ट देना पड़ेगा
जिसप मुझे कनेक्शन को भेजना है तो चलो फिर
एक कमेंट मेंशन करते हैं
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन।
ठीक है? तो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के लिए हम सबसे
पहले यहां लिखते हैं आपका अटैकर आईपी।
अटैकर
आईपी और मेरी मशीन का अटैक काली Linux की
मशीन का आईपी क्या है? मेरा मेरे हिसाब से
मेरा है 192.168.119.134
कुछ होगा तो मैं देख लूं देख लूंगा फिर।
और यहां पर आपको क्या करना है? काली
लinक्स का IP एड्रेस देना है। यह आपको
चेंज करना है आपके अकॉर्डिंग। मेरे वाला
मत यूज़ करना फालतू में। ठीक है? उसके बाद
यहां पर हम अटैकर पोर्ट
अटैकर पोर्ट
अटैकर पोर्ट इक्वल। अब मैं मेंशन 44 ये
पोर्ट मैं यूज़ करने वाला हूं। अटैक एटी
अटैकर पोर्ट। ठीक है? हमने यह कर लिया है।
ओके नेक्स्ट यहां तक हो गया मेरा कंप्लीट।
भैया मेरा एक और सवाल है। रुको रुको रुको
यहां तक कंप्लीट हुआ है। लेकिन हमें अभी
तक क्या नहीं किया है? इस पी लोड को
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं किया है। तो चलो भैया और
यहां पर आ जाते हैं हम यहां पर यहां पर
अभी हम इसको एग्जीक्यूट करने वाले हैं। तो
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए हम क्या यूज़
करेंगे?
ओबीj सेल डॉट रन मेथड का यूज़ करेंगे। उसके
बाद इसका पीएस एक्स फिल्ट्रेट
एक्स फिल्ट्रेट सीएमडी
ठीक है देन उसके बाद हम यूज़ करेंगे जीरो
उसके बाद ट्रू सेम देन ये तो हमने कर लिया
इसके लिए
उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है भाई वो
रिपोर्ट डिलीट भी करनी है जब मेरा डेटा
ट्रांसफर हो गया कनेक्शन कनेक्शन क्लोज भी
हो गया मुझे उसको डिलीट भी करना है तो
डिलीट करने के लिए मुझे क्या करूंगा मैं
fso डॉट डिलीट
डॉट डिलीट मेथड जैसा कि मैंने स्टार्टिंग
में बताया था डिलीट फाइल उसके बाद मेंशन
कर रहा हूं मैं टेम रिपोर्ट
टेम रिपोर्ट ठीक है टेम रिपोर्ट और इसके
बाद मैं क्या करने वाला हूं इसको क्लोज
करना होगा एंड इफ को एंड इफ को मैं क्लोज
भी करने वाला हूं क्योंकि इसको क्लोज करना
पड़ेगा ऑब्वियसली हो गया उसके बाद एक और
कोड लिख रहा हूं वैसे सेफ्टी पर्पस से
मेंशन कर रहा हूं मैं सेट अह
सब्जेक्ट सेल आप सर्च कर लेना इक्वल टू
नथिंग इसको मैं क्लियर कर रहा हूं कंप्लीट
होने के बाद नथिंग सेट कर दिया खाली कर
रहा हूं बिल्कुल बिल्कुल क्लियर कर रहा
हूं हटा रहा हूं उनको
नथिंग ठीक है ये हो गया और यहां पर मेरा
ये कंप्लीट हो गया अब मुझे एक चीज और एक
डाउट है आप लोगों से पूछना है कि हमने
मलेशियस पेलोड डिजाइन कर लिया किया
और यूजर ने क्या किया? यूजर के पास भेज
दिया और यूजर के पास जैसे ही हमने भेजा
पी अभी एग्जीक्यूट नहीं करेगा।
ये अभी एग्जीक्यूट नहीं करेगा। इसका कारण
पता है एग्जीक्यूट क्यों नहीं करेगा?
इसका किसी को कारण पता है कि एग्जीक्यूट
क्यों नहीं करने वाला?
क्योंकि
इसमें हमने ऐसा कोई कोड लिखा ही नहीं कि
जिसकी वजह से जैसे ही मैं इनेबल कंटेंट
करूं। ऐसा कोई ट्रिगर मैंने पास किया ही
नहीं कि इनेबल कंटेंट करते ही क्या हो?
मेरा कोड एग्जीक्यूट हो। मेरा कोड
एग्जीक्यूट
हो। इनेबल कंटेंट करते ही मेरा कोड
एग्जीक्यूट हो। ऐसा कोड तो मैंने लिखा ही
नहीं इसमें कहीं पर भी
नहीं लिखा ना मैंने
ऐसा कोड तो ऐसा कोड हम सबसे फ्रंट में
लिखते हैं।
तो चलो फिर वे माय फ्रंट तो नाउ नाउ नाउ
यहां पर लिखेंगे सबसे पहले। ऐसा कोड
लिखेंगे हम यहां पर ऑटो एग्जीक्यूशन के
लिए। सबसे पहले हम किसके लिए लिखेंगे? ऑटो
एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए। ठीक है? ऑटो
एग्जीक्यूशन
ऑटो एग्जीक्यूशन ट्रिगर्स के लिए। इसके
लिए दो ट्रिगर्स हैं जो हम यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। पहला कौन सा है जो आपको यूज़ करना है।
प्राइवेट
सब
डॉक्यूमेंट अंडर
ओपन ये ऑटोमेटिक जैसे ये क्या करेगा इनेबल
कंटेंट करोगे तो ये ऑटोमेटिकली आपके कोड
को एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे। ठीक है? तो सबसे
पहले मैं इसमें एक सेफ्टी पर्पस के लिए
लिख देता हूं ऑन एरर। यह आपको यूज़ करना
चाहिए 100%।
इसका मतलब क्या है? कि अगर किसी भी कारण
से, किसी भी प्रिविलजेस की वजह से कोई भी
एरर आई तो प्लीज उसको चुपचाप मेरे कोड को
रिज्यूम करना। उस एरर को थ्रो मत करना।
ठीक है? उस एरर को थ्रो मत करना। ये ऐसा
बोल रहा है।
इसका मतलब ये है ऑन रिज्यूम नेक्स्ट। ऑन
एरर आर रिज्यूम नेक्स्ट। उसके बाद मैं
क्या करने वाला हूं? कॉल करने वाला हूं।
किसको? मेरे फंक्शन को। मेरे फंक्शन को
कॉल करने वाला हूं इस वाले को।
ओके। अरे भैया कर रहा हूं।
ये रहा
यहां करूंगा मैं फंक्शन कॉल। ये रहा हो
गया पहला। दूसरा हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
एक और है। दूसरा एक और है सब
ऑटो ओपन। ऑटो ओपन
ऑटो ओपन इट एंटर। और सेम इसमें कॉपी कर
देंगे दोनों को। तो अभी आपका मशियस पेलोड
तैयार है एग्जीक्यूट होने के लिए। आपका
मशियस पे लोड तैयार है एग्जीक्यूट होने के
लिए।
अंडरस्टुड आपका जो मशियस पे लोड है तैयार
है एग्जीक्यूट होने के लिए। एग्जीक्यूट
करके दिखाना है।
तो एग्जीक्यूट करके दिखाना है। तो चलो मैं
इसको एक फाइल को क्लोज कर देता हूं। इसको
भी क्लोज करता हूं। इसको भी क्लोज करता
हूं और इसको भी क्लोज करता हूं और इसको भी
मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं क्योंकि इसका भी
कोई काम बचा नहीं। आप लोग बचे हो क्लोज
नहीं कर सकता जिनको मैं। अब मुझे आपके लिए
मशीन को ऑन करना पड़ेगा। इस मशीन को हम
करेंगे ऑन।
तो काली लक्स को हम सबसे पहले ऑन करते
हैं।
ऑन।
बाद में दिखाना।
ऐसी क्लासेस कहीं पर मिलेंग बताओ।
कौन सिखाता है ऐसे?
नोबडी। कोई नहीं किसी को बताता। आप ही लोग
बताओ ऐसी क्लासेस कहीं पर है?
अभी तो क्या है? देखो
ये तो जस्ट नॉर्मल पर्पस से है। इसको
थोड़ा और एडवांस करेंगे हम कोड को नेक्स्ट
क्लासेस में।
वेट वेट वेट चलो चलो।
अरे यार व्हाट हैपन?
इसको मुझे अभी क्या कीबोर्ड का इशू रहता
है इनमें?
तो मुझे इसको फिर से रिस्ट करना पड़ेगा शट
डाउन करके।
इट विल टेक टाइम। तब तक के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं? टारगेट मशीन पे इसको भेज देते
हैं। मेरा Window 10 Pro है। इस पे भेज
देता हूं मैं।
हम हम
डॉक्यूमेंट पे जाएंगे। इसको उठाएंगे। गाइस
माय फाइल।
एंड दिस इज द माय फाइल। यह रही। इसको मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं? कॉपी।
सेम
शेम मशीन है। इसको मैं एक यहां पर मैं
इसको डिलीट कर देता हूं। यहां पर डिलीट
है। श्योर तो यहां पर मैं क्या करता हूं?
एक पेस्ट कर देता हूं।
ओके। फाइल यहां पर पेस्ट नहीं हुई।
यहां पर पेस्ट कर दिया।
आ गया। ओके। डबल क्लिक करें। बाद में
करेंगे क्योंकि हमने अभी काली ऑन नहीं
किया हुआ। तो अभी हम काली को ऑन करते हैं।
मैं इतना तो सिखा दूंगा कि आपको आईडिया
मिल जाए। बाकी तो और डेप्थ में आपको खुद
जाना पड़ेगा। बुक्स पढ़नी पड़गी। आपको
इंटरनल्स के बारे में पढ़ना पड़ेगा। तब
जाके आपको फायदा मिलेगा कि ओके हां
इंटरनल्स में क्या-क्या कर सकता हूं।
लेकिन आज के टाइम में भी 2026 में भी
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट बेस्ड अटैक बहुत हो रहे
हैं। बहुत ज्यादा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इट्स ओके। चलो हमारी मशीन ऑन हो गई है और
अभी हम काम करते हैं। क्या करना पड़ा
हमें? Netcat लिसनर हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा? स्टार्ट करना पड़ेगा। और मैं क्या
करता हूं इसको?
ओके। ओके और सबसे पहले हम ये चेक कर लेते
हैं इस उसके तो हम करेंगे ही हम करते हैं
एन सी हफन
एल हफन पी
44 44 और उसके बाद ये रहा ये रहा ठीक है
सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt यहां पर मैं इसको
कर देता हूं एंटर लिसनिंग मोड ऑन कर दिया
है नाउ हम क्या करते हैं डबल क्लिक करते
हैं वे इज माय फाइल दिस इज माय फाइल
यहां पर जैसे मैंने डबल क्लिक किया
फाइल अभी ओपन नहीं हुई है। राइट क्लिक ओपन
कर देना हमें। फाइल को मैंने ओपन किया।
देखो
ओके। ठीक है। देखो वो मेरा कोई आया था।
फुल स्क्रीन में दिखा देता हूं। अभी क्या
है? ग्लोबल बैंक एंटरप्राइज सोनसो सोसो
एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड सोनसो देखो क्लिक इनेबल
एडिटिंग ये इनेबल इनेबल करें
इनेबल करें
और उससे पहले मैं एक काम करता हूं इनेबल
करने से पहले यहां पर चलते हैं और मैं
इसको पहले
आपको इसके लिए एक और टैब ओपन करके दिखा
देता हूं। वेयर इज़ माय न्यू टैब। न्यू टैब
ओपन करता हूं। यहां पर एलएस कर देता हूं।
एक फाइल है पहले से ही। इसको मैं डिलीट कर
देता हूं।
रिमूव
आप बोलोगे सर पहले से ही था आपके पास। ठीक
है? एलएस कर देता हूं। कोई फाइल नहीं है
इससे पहले। ठीक है? इससे पहले कोई भी फाइल
नहीं है। ठीक है? ये लिसनिंग मोड में है।
इनेबल करते हैं। तो ए मैंने क्या कर दिया?
इनेबल।
ओ हो हो समथिंग इज
प्रॉब्लमेटिक। हमारी कोई एरर है। और एरर
क्या है?
कोई कंपाइलर एरर है। ओके ओके
प्राइवेट फंक्शन।
अभी हमें एरर फाइंड आउट करनी है। हमने कोड
में क्या एरर की है जिसकी वजह से प्रॉब्लम
क्रिएट हुई।
समथिंग इज हैपनिंग हियर
नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग तो व्हाट इज
इफ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां भी सब सही है।
एक इसको इट रन करके देखते हैं पहले।
वेरिएबल नॉट डिफाइन
कौन सा वेरिएबल ऑब्जेक्ट एफएस और टैब
टेम रिपोर्ट भी है। सीएमडी भी है।
सीएमडी भी है।
ओके
विल इज नो डिफाइंड
सही पकड़े
एन ओ टी एच आई एन जी नथिंग गुड यार
कंट्रोल एस इसको क्लोज करके फिर से देखते
हैं हम
डॉक्यूमेंट को क्लोज करते हैं।
चलो
एंड एंड एंड एंड क्योंकि जो जैसा हमें
बिहेव करवाना है तो अभी मैं इसको क्लोज
करता हूं। चलो फिर से इसको डबल क्लिक एंड
ओपन
इनेबल कंटेंट इज इट लिसनिंग ओके ये बंद हो
गया
यहां पर ओपन किया यहां किया यहां पर इनेबल
कंटेंट
अभी यहां पर एक इशू हुआ है जो हमने शायद
कोड नहीं लिखा और लिख दिया हो तो अच्छी
बात है।
दिस फाइल इज ऑन नेटवर्क लोकेशन ऑन अदर
यूजर यू कैन हैव एक्सेस टू दिस नेटवर्क और
इसका इसके लिए काम हुआ चलो यह इधर चेक कर
लेते हैं हम पहले कैट करके देखते हैं
सिस्टम रिपोर्टxt
लो हमारा काम हो गया हमारा काम हो गया और
इसको हमें देखो यस करो नो करो एक एक गलती
हमसे हो रखी है इसमें वो कोड नहीं
एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है उसके लिए
इसको नो कर दिया मैंने कोई दिक्कत नहीं
यहां पर एक कोड था था ना वो हिडन था यह
हटना चाहिए था मतलब मैं क्या चाहता था कि
मेरा जो माइक्रो कोड रन करे तो यह जो पॉप
अप था ना ये जो वार्निंग लाइट थी ये हाइड
हो जाए और इसके नीचे जो कोड था वो सामने आ
जाए बट ऐसा कुछ हुआ नहीं आई डोंट नो कि
इसको हमें थोड़ा सा और इस पे काम करना
पड़ेगा तो नेक्स्ट जब हम इसका एडवांस और
भी वर्जन यूज़ करेंगे मतलब कि इसको थोड़ा
सा और जो मै कोड अभी जिस तरीके से हमने
डिजाइन किया है इसको थोड़ा और एनहांस
करेंगे सो दैट कि हमारे जो इवेज थोड़ा सा
थोड़ा सा इवेज बन जाए ना कि कंप्लीट कभी
थोड़ा सा इवेज क्योंकि डायरेक्टली क्या है
कि इसको आपका जो डिफेंडर ही पकड़ लेगा।
ओके तो इसको हम अभी क्लोज कर देते हैं और
उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन देखते हैं जो यहां पर
हमें मिली है। देखो
ये रहा सारी इनेशन आ गई उस फाइल के अंदर।
देखो
ये रही देखो अंडरस्टुड गाइस जो हमने देखो
बनाई थी। टेस्ट केस टेस्ट केस सोनसो यह
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कितने सॉफ्टवेयर में इंस्टॉल है कौन से
इंस्टॉल नहीं है विद वर्जन नंबर
सबको समझ में आ गया
ओके
सबको समझ में आ गया? तो, यह था आज की सेशन
का प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन। आई होप कि
सबको मजा आया होगा और सबने सेशन में एंजॉय
किया होगा। वेट इसको मिनिमाइज कर देता
हूं। इसको मिनिमाइज कर देते हैं हम। एंड
बताओ आज का सेशन क्या था? काफी लॉन्ग सेशन
रहा है। बट आई होप कि इट इज मोर
प्रैक्टिकल देन प्रीवियस सेशन और जितने भी
सेशन उससे ज्यादा प्रैक्टिकल है।
एकडमी को कांटेक्ट कैसे करें? तो आप एकडमी
को कांटेक्ट कर सकते हो। यहां पर
डेफ्रोनिक्स पेज पे डेफोनिक्स सर्च कीजिए।
डेफ़ोनिक्स एकडमी पर जाइए और यहां पर आप
कांटेक्ट कर सकते हो। यहां पर कॉल इस नंबर
पे कॉल कीजिए। आपको
इस रिस्पांस मिल जाएगा।
इट्स ओके। मेरी छोटी स्क्रीन दिख रही है
तो नेक्स्ट टाइम जो स्क्रीन बड़ी हो जाएगी।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो उसका इशू मत
कीजिए। फिर मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि अगर
आपको फिर भी क्या करना है कि मेरे
WhatsApp उसको मेरे से कांटेक्ट करना है
तो आपको मेरा Telegram ग्रुप ज्वाइन करना
चाहिए। हमारा Telegram ग्रुप कहां पर है?
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन लिंक में।
देखो देयर आर लॉट ऑफ कॉल्स वी आर गेटिंग
फ्रॉम एव्री स्टूडेंट्स। तो थोड़ा समय
लगता है। कुछ कॉल्स इग्नोर भी हो जाती है
क्योंकि बहुत सारी ऐसी कॉल्स होती हैं
जहां पर जिनका कोई मतलब नहीं। हमारे पास
लिटरली मैं आपको बताता हूं ऐसी कॉल आती है
सर इवन मेरे स्टूडेंट की। अब मैं पढ़ा
पढ़ा रहा हूं। सर मुझे एक काम करना है कि
कोई ऐसा पेलोड कि मैं मतलब पूरा मिलेशियस
पेलोड कर करना है। तो भाई आप क्या काम
करते हो? पर्पज क्या है? सर पर्पस तो नहीं
बता सकता मैं आपको। तो ऐसेसे भयंकर कॉल
आती है हमारे पास।
यू आर वेरी एक्साइटेड। तो इसके पास
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन पूरा मॉडल बचा हुआ
है। लेटरल मूवमेंट आपका बचा हुआ है। और ये
सब स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको ये
बेसिक बड़े-बड़े मॉड्यूल बचे हुए हैं। एडी
आप जब ये कंप्लीट कर लो उसके बाद हम एडी
भी करेंगे। एडी पर पेड रहेगा। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी बिल्कुल जीरो से एक लेवल तक हम
लेके जाएंगे। एक्सपर्ट लेवल तो नहीं कह
सकता बट इंटरमीडिएट लेवल या एडवांस लेवल
तक मैं उसको लेके जाने वाला हूं जिसमें
पेड रहेगा अराउंड वन मंथ या 20 डेज टू 30
डेज की हम एक ट्रेनिंग प्लान करूंगा वो भी
मैं करूंगा ये कोर्स जस्ट जैसे एंड होने
वाला होगा हम एडी कवर करेंगे तो काफी
मॉड्यूल्स बचे हुए हैं। जैसे कि उसके बाद
इतने तो बचे हुए हैं। नेक्स्ट आप लोगों का
इंटरेस्ट रहा। आप लोगों ने थोड़ा सा कुछ
और मतलब कि इंटरेस्ट दिखाया इसको शेयर
किया और आप लोग मेरे से ज्यादा जुड़े तो
मेबी और मॉड्यूल्स इसमें इंट्रोड्यूस कर
दूं मैं जो बचे हुए हैं। अदरवाइज फिर मैं
मजबूर कर दोगे आप मेरे को जबरदस्ती ये
क्लास ये सीरीज डिस्कंटिन्यू करने के लिए।
मैं भी डिस्कंटिन्यू नहीं करना चाहता।
लेकिन अगर आप लोग मेरे को मजबूर करोगे
डिस्कंटिन्यू करने के लिए तो फिर तो मुझे
करना ही पड़ेगा। तो मैं आप लोगों से
उम्मीद यही करता हूं कि ज्यादा से ज्यादा
इसको शेयर कीजिए। आप सेम टाइम जितने उसको
लाइक तो कीजिए वह भी नहीं करते आप लोग कुछ
नहीं करते जस्ट यू आर कमिंग एंड
नथिंग आई एम मैं कुछ नहीं कहना चाहता तो
इट्स ओके
ठीक है तो
आई होप सबको समझ में आ गया होगा
तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं। तो ये चैट मेरी
टीम देख रही है तो हमारी टीम मेंबर्स
प्लीज अगर आप लोग इधर अवेलेबल हो क्लास
में या कभी भी आप अगर इन तो प्लीज
कांटेक्ट
इनके साथ कांटेक्ट कीजिए दे आर लिटरली
वेरी
मतलब बोल सकते हो कि तो फ्रस्ट्रेटेड हो
चुके होंगे तो प्लीज उनसे कांटेक्ट करने
की कोशिश कीजिए तो मैं बोलता हूं तो इट्स
ओके तो सेशन को फिर एंड करते हैं तो
थैंक यू एवरीवन एंड बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन
सी यू फॉर और नेक्स्ट सेशन आपको नेक्स्ट
सेशन की अनाउंसमेंट जल्दी मिल जाएगी। मे
बी टुमारो ना हो डे आफ्टर टुमारो हो। ओके
तो बाय बाय एवरीवन। गुड नाइट एवरीवन।